want to be happy build a life not just a
business hey it's evan carmichael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know you've got so much more inside
you you've got michael jordan level
genius at something so today let's live
your best believe life and get some
incredible motivation from the one and
only joe dispenza
enjoy
change is so hard
so then let's offer another alternative
well when you begin to create from the
field
instead of from matter
the only way you can do that is you have
to learn how to take all of your
attention off your body and become a
nobody
take all of your attention off all the
people in your life that you give so
much of your attention and energy to
because you have an emotion associated
with them
and get beyond all the people in your
life and go from someone to a no one now
if you've worked your whole life being a
someone or if you've been working your
whole life thinking that you're your
body you're gonna have to work a little
harder because that's your identity
that's what you're associated with and
it's a long time of conditioning it's a
lot of unwanted and if this was easy
everybody would be doing it so then you
have to go
get beyond all the things in your life
your cell phone your computer your car
and literally go from something to
nothing you have to take all your
attention off the place you work the
place you live the place you need to be
the place you're sitting and go from
somewhere to nowhere
you got to stop thinking about the
predictable future in the familiar past
and go right into the present moment and
go from some time to no time and if you
do that properly
you become pure consciousness and that's
how you enter the field
now we've done the research on this we
call it getting beyond the self now once
you are pure consciousness
you're taking all of your attention off
this three-dimensional reality
now where you place your attention is
where you place your energy so if you've
taken all of your attention off of
everything material
there's only one place you're going to
wind up and that is the in immaterial
realm called the quantum field an
invisible field of energy that unifies
and connects everything material
so now when you're creating from the
field and you combine a clear intention
with an elevated emotion and you're
connected and you feel connected
the suggestion of an alternative way to
create
is that when there's a vibrational match
between your energy
and some future reality
you actually no longer have to go
anywhere to get it you're actually the
vortex and you will collapse space and
time and draw the experience to you now
that to me
is a lot more fun
because the experience
is the unknown you can't predict when
it's going to happen or how it's going
to happen because if you can predict it
it's known so then you have to lay down
the very thing
you use your whole life to get what you
want
for something greater to occur now that
goes against
generations untold of conditioning and a
lifetime of habituation believing that
we're were trapped in this material
world and yet i can i can say to you
without a doubt
that once you understand that formula
and once you know how to create that
kind of brain and heart coherence
the side effect of that
is a change in biology
neurologically chemically hormonally
genetically we've measured it we've seen
gene regulation changes in four days
more brain coherence more heart
coherence your brain's working better
your heart is you're trusting your heart
it's open there's different chemicals
that are released oxytocin suppresses
survival centers resets the baseline of
a person's trauma or shock
your immune system goes up
you you lengthen your telomeres we've
measured that too so you're changing the
future of your body you're extending
your life
that's evidence right so we we have the
evidence to know that it could happen
because we've measured it but the real
evidence
is watching the testimonial of someone
who says i had stage four cancer
i was told as a 41 year old woman that i
wouldn't live for more than two months
and i have no
evidence of cancer in my body at all or
someone that's a physician who has
parkinson's disease that's tried
everything from the medical route and
has one transcendental moment and their
tremors and their pain are gone then now
they're chewing food they're swallowing
they're blowing their nose they're
standing up on their own
that's energy affecting matter so we
have
hundreds and hundreds of testimonials
of people that not only healed their
body
but created pretty profoundly magical
things in their life
so you have evidence in the scientific
world you have evidence in the practical
world and evidence
is the loudest voice right now the brain
is a record of the past it's an artifact
of everything we've learned and
experienced to this moment
so
most people wake up in the morning and
they think about their problems and
their problems are memories that are
etched in their brain that are connected
to certain people and certain problems
at certain times in certain places and
the moment they start thinking of their
problems they're thinking in the past
the challenge is that every one of those
problems has an emotion associated with
it and emotions really are a record of
the past so the moment you feel unhappy
the moment you feel suffering the moment
you feel
fear now your body's in the past so it's
the thought being the language of the
brain and the feeling being the language
of the body and how we think and how we
feel creates our state of being so
many people reaffirmed their state of
being completely uh by the past and so
it only takes a thought and a feeling an
image an emotion
a stimulus and response to start the
conditioning process so we start to
condition the brain and body hardwire
the brain condition the body emotionally
into the past the problem is the body's
so objective
that it doesn't know the difference
between the real life experience that's
creating the emotion and the emotion
we're creating by memory alone the
body's believing it's living in the same
past environment
24 hours a day 7 days a week 365 days a
year so
then the person gets up and then they
run through the same routine as they
always do and
in time their body moves into a state of
autopilot now their body is a set of
programs a habit that's dragging them
into the same future based on what they
did in the past and so to change them
also requires being greater than the
emotions that have been conditioned into
the body and the habituations that have
been conditioned into the body in the
predictable future so
we have to understand then that change
requires not only being greater than the
environment
but also being greater than our body
which is really for the most part been
conditioned to be the mind that's what a
habit is
so then
to change then to be greater than the
body to be greater than the environment
and be greater than time instead of
living in the familiar past which is the
known and the predictable future which
is the known you teach people how to
settle into the present moment and
that's the unknown and most people that
the unknown represents a very
threatening place and so when people
start to do meditation as an example and
their body starts looking for an arousal
wants to get up and do things they think
they can't meditate but in fact if they
can settle their body back down into the
present moment and lower the volume to
that anger to that frustration to the
fear to the sadness
it's like training an animal now you're
telling the body it's no longer the mind
that you're the mind and our research
shows there's a liberation of energy the
body starts expanding and relaxing into
the present moment instead of getting up
and checking your cell phone or doing
something and you notice that propensity
instead of responding to it and say i
can't meditate you settle your body back
down into the present moment now you're
executing a will
that's greater than the program because
most people lose their free will to a
set of programs and it's the act of
doing this to be greater than the
conditions our environment to be greater
than our body is the mind and and to be
greater than time
it all of a sudden causes the person to
start believing in themselves a little
bit more and that's when
possibility starts to unfold if your
brain is a record of the past
and you are living by the same emotions
that have defined you
for the last 10 years
and you keep thinking the same thoughts
that make the same chemicals and those
same chemicals drive the same thoughts
then your body
as the unconscious mind
does not know the difference between an
actual experience in your life that
creates an emotion
and an emotion that you're creating by
thought alone
and so your body is believing it's in
the same past experience
24 hours a day
seven days a week
365 days a year and your body is
programmed into the past
and you can create a new future
holding on to the emotions of the past
how many people understand what i'm
talking about
so then
when you react
to someone or something in your life
you have a choice
that when an event changes how you feel
there's a chemical change that's taking
place in your body
and most people don't think they can
control their emotional reactions
and so then when you react to some
co-worker
or some relative
or somebody in traffic
the moment you react emotionally you are
altered chemically
and if you don't know how to control
your emotional reaction after that event
and you allow those emotions to linger
for hours or days
you know what that's called
that's called a mood
hey
juanito
what's wrong with you
oh i'm in a mood
really why are you in a mood
well this thing happened to me four days
ago
and i'm having one long emotional
reaction
and if you keep that same refractory
period going on for weeks or months
that's called a temperament
hey
why is she so angry i don't know
why are you so angry why are you so
bitter why are you so enchilada
because i had this experience
seven months ago
and i'm
memorizing my emotional reaction
and if you keep that same refractory
period going on for years on end
that's called a personality trait
and people wear their emotions on their
sleeve
and that's who they think they are
and they will talk about the past to
validate why they're not creating the
life that they want
so then if you wake up in the morning
mexico city
and you are not being defined by a
vision that's bigger than you
and it doesn't get you out of bed and
inspire you into possibility
and you get up
living from the old hardware of the past
and the old emotions stored in your body
do you know what's going to happen to
you
you're going to wake up and you're going
to open your eyes
and you're going to see the same people
and go to the same places and do the
exact same thing at the exact same time
and the moment you open your eyes
all of a sudden now it's your external
environment that's controlling how you
think and feel
because you have a neurological network
in your brain for every person you know
every place that you go everything that
you own everything that you do
and the moment you open your eyes and
you see the same people and go to the
same places and do the exact same thing
at the exact same time it's your
external environment that's turning on
different circuits in your brain
causing you to think equal to everything
that you know
and you told me you believe that your
thoughts have something to do with your
destiny
and as long as you're
thinking equal to your environment
you keep creating the same life
to change
to truly change is to think greater than
your environment
to think greater than the circumstances
in your life to think greater than the
conditions in your world and every great
person in history knew this
whether it was mahatma gandhi martin
luther king the wright brothers joan of
arc
they all had a vision
when was the last time you sat with your
heart and just worked with it like so
that it's not contracted and afraid and
protected
it takes practice to to do that and and
so we we work with people in letting
them
we give them numerous opportunities
to practice this over and over and over
again and sooner or later pedal by pedal
it starts to bloom and all of a sudden
there's an authentic smile on their face
and once energy meets the heart it goes
right to the brain we have
we did this study where we hooked up an
electrocardiogram to an
electroencephalogram and an
electroencephalogram is a brain mapping
machine so we measure 19 or 26 different
compartments and we're looking to see
all different kind of activity in the
brain
but we measured the heart along with it
and when the heart starts beating
coherently
in a sense of order
like like taking a big sheet jay and
going like that the heart sends a wave
right up to the brain
and the brain goes into these beautiful
states of alpha the heart is telling the
brain it's safe to create again it's
safe to imagine it's safe to dream of a
new future
and
there's the stroke volume of the heart
in order and then you see these two or
three seconds of beautiful coherent
alpha the brain is in it's it's in that
creative state then there's a pause and
it happens again and
it's it's it's beauty it's a it's a
symphony
if you don't have that mechanism you can
have all the intention in the world
but there's no carrier wave i mean
when people when they make energy uh
reach their heart there's an external
field that's created it's it's it's
magnetic it's it's it's measurable
and that energy
is frequency and if that frequency is
coherent it can carry the intent
or thought on a coherent brain of that
future the energy of suffering
cannot carry the thought of health or
wealth it's not consistent with it it
carries a different set of thoughts
so then
the training then
is getting people into those hard states
because
once they start trading that fear or
that pain or that frustration or trying
or whatever forcing you know control
for gratitude and they just let all that
go and i say to them listen
if you can't feel gratitude if you can't
feel love i just want to know what
you've been practicing feeling every day
because that feeling that you're
practicing is what you're always feeling
now let's practice feeling something
else in the beginning it's not going to
be easy but you got to keep following
the formula keep doing it keep doing it
keep doing it well
when i start feeling gratitude it's very
interesting because
the emotional signature of gratitude
is that something wonderful just
happened to you
something favorable is happening to you
right so
you've just received something or you're
receiving something you say thank you so
gratitude
is the ultimate state of receiving
emotionally
so when you move into a state of
gratitude and you open your heart you
will accept believe and surrender to the
thoughts equal to that emotional state
and you'll program your autonomic
nervous system into a different destiny
you could say i'm healthy i'm healthy
i'm healthy i'm wealthy and wealthy and
wealthy and wealthy and free i'm free
i'm free and your body is conditioned in
the misery and it's saying no you're not
and that thought stops right at the
brain stem
it never makes it to the body because
the body is on a different program
so then
while the person starts trading that and
they start opening their heart well
their immune system gets stronger by 50
percent 50
in three days they start making
immunoglobulins their bodies natural
defense against viruses and bacteria 50
percent not a little bit
a lot that's that's one study and so
trading that
telling the body it's in the in the
environment where it already happened
and so that's when the miracles start
happening that's when people say
i'm not doing anything well of course
you're not
you don't have to your personality
creates your personal reality
that's it
and your personality is made up of how
you think
how you act
and how you feel
so the present personality who's
listening to this podcast has created
the present personal reality called
their life
so if you believe what i just said then
in order for you to create a new
personal reality
a new life
you're gonna have to change your
personality in other words
nothing changes in your life until you
change that's the way it is
so turns out the ninety percent of the
thoughts that we think on a daily basis
are the same thoughts as the day before
same thoughts lead to the same choices
same choices lead to the same behaviors
same behaviors create the same
experiences the same experiences produce
the same feelings and the same emotions
and those same feelings and emotions
begin to influence our very same
thoughts and our biology
our neural circuitry our neurochemistry
our
hormones our gene expression our immune
system
all stay the same because we're staying
the same so then there's a principle in
neuroscience that says that nerve cells
that fire together
wire together you keep thinking the same
thoughts you keep making the same
choices you keep doing the same things
you keep creating the same experiences
that stamp the same networks of neurons
into the same exact patterns all for the
reaffirming of the same feeling and you
do that for 10 years on end
the firing and wiring of those circuitry
begins to hardwire the brain into a very
finite signature
that box in the brain that's created
is the same level of mind and
if you keep doing that it becomes
automatic
it turns out that 95 of who we are by
the time we're in the middle of our life
is a set of memorized behaviors
automatic emotional reactions constant
habits hardwired attitudes beliefs
perceptions
that have happened just because we we've
just fired and wired it the same way so
there's a good possibility then in order
for us to change
we better start thinking about what
we've been thinking about in changing we
have to become conscious
of our unconscious habits and behaviors
and modify them
we've got to look at these feelings that
we feel every single day instead of just
thinking it's a feeling say what is this
is this guilt is this sadness is this
unhappiness is this pain is it
frustration is it resentment what is the
feeling that i'm living by the majority
of my day now
that's lighting a match in a dark place
in neuroscience it's called
metacognition
the word meditation means
to become familiar with that's what it
means so the more familiar with you are
i can't with i can't it's too hard i'm
never going to change it's my ex's fault
it's my boss's fault it's my country's
fault it's the government it's the
weather it's my pain whatever that
thought is that you accept believe and
surrender to on a daily basis that's
automatic
you have to become so conscious of that
unconscious thought
that it doesn't slip by your awareness
unnoticed you got to catch yourself
saying
i'm tired i'm unhappy at someone else's
fault do you complain do you blame do
you make excuses do you feel sorry for
yourself
that that personality
has to change in order to create a new
life so then you have to become so aware
of your unconscious habits that you
don't go unconscious to them in your
waking day then you got to sit in the
fire
of those emotions
and you gotta watch those emotions come
up and you have to sit with them and
know that there's something on the other
side of them now this is where most
people get up and say i can't meditate
or i'm going to call up my friend or i'm
going to get on social media and make a
post i'm going to turn on the football
game i'm going to get distracted because
i need something out there
to make this go away
and what we're saying is we're not
relying on anything out there that's the
that's the hypnosis that's the
conditioning
we want you to just become so familiar
with that feeling that you catch
yourself in your waking day the moment
you start
feeling sad and your energy drops ah you
catch yourself so
there's an unlearning process
or breaking the habit of being the old
self process that requires
a lot of attention
a lot of awareness and it takes energy
you gotta stay conscious right if you
think about
great leaders in history
that changed the course of many
different cultures
what they did that was so important is
they had a vision of that future
and they were able to
have other people come out of their
resting emotional state
and begin to see that vision that they
were seeing and move them into an
elevated emotional state and when they
changed their energy
those people could share that same
vision well if you combine a clear
intention in an elevated emotion
those two ingredients change people's
state of being now the person who just
moved biologically from living in the
past to living in a new future in the
present moment and that's what caused
millions of people to begin to make
different choices to behave differently
to do different things and if you get
enough people doing that because of
mirror neurons everybody's observing
everybody do it and you create a
collective consciousness and great
leaders
have the ability to
based on the core principles whether
it's justice or freedom or equality to
have people see that same vision and
then move them out of their resting
state into an elevated emotion and then
when they do that properly those people
can see that vision if you can't change
a person's energy
they'll never see that vision because
they'll be viewing the future
through the lens of the past the
emotions of the past and so great
leaders have the ability to to have
people begin to see the same vision how
does the person become the person they
are
and why do they keep their health
condition the same and well
most people your brain is a record of
the past it's an artifact fact of
everything you've learned and
experienced at this moment so most
people wake up in the morning if you
think that your thoughts have something
to do with your destiny they start
thinking about their problems and those
problems are just memories that are
etched in their brain that are connected
to certain people and objects and
certain things at certain times and
places and the moment they start
thinking about their problems they're
thinking in the past now because every
one of those problems has an emotion
associated with them
the moment they start feeling unhappy or
feeling sad now their body's in the past
because thoughts are the language of the
brain and feelings of the language of
the body and how we think and how we
feel creates our state of being though
the problem is is that the person thinks
of the problem feels the emotion and
that is a thought and feeling that's a
image and an emotion it's a stimulus and
response and that starts the
conditioning process to get the body
emotionally conditioned into the past
now here's the crazy part about it yes
the familiar past
emotionally
is producing dramatic effects on the
body because the body's so objective
that it does not know the difference
between the real life experience that's
creating that emotion and the emotion
that person is fabricating by thought or
memory alone the body's believing it's
living in the same past experience
seven days a week 365 days a year and
the problem with that is is that the
environment signals the gene that's
epigenetics and the end product of an
experience and the environment there's
an emotion so the person is keeping the
same gene regulated because the body's
believing it's living in the same
environmental condition so
getting that person to step outside of
that familiar known territory into the
unknown
where there is uncertainty and have them
be comfortable there and begin to think
about how they are going to think the
new model of reality is about causing an
effect
that means then you have to feel
gratitude every day for your new
experience to occur
you can't wait for your success to feel
empowered
you have to be empowered to create the
success
and when you teach people how to do this
and they move into a new state of being
they begin to create the life that they
want
how many people are still with me
but to the materialists they would say
well no
no no no i'm gonna wait for my money to
come and then i'm gonna give thanks
and those people pretty much are living
by the emotions of the past
and if you're living by the emotions of
the past you are viewing your future
through the lens of the past
and your vision will fade
because when you bring up an elevated
emotion you will see the vision clearly
and leaders in history that changed the
world knew how to change a culture look
at martin luther king
he talked about justice and then got
enough people inspired
that they felt empowered enough to do
something about it
people came out of the resting state
and so then you share the same brain as
martin luther king
and being defined by a vision of the
future begins to change a culture
but most people have the same thoughts
of the same intentions and they live by
the same familiar emotions and for the
most part they're in their past while
the brain is organized to reflect
everything you know in your life your
brain is a record of your environment
so it begs the question
does the environment control your
thinking
or does your thinking control the
environment so if you wake up every
morning and you do the same things and
you go to the same places and you see
the same people
and you react in the same way and you
perform the same behaviors
it really is the external environment
that's turning on different circuits in
your brain causing you to think equal to
everything that you know
as long as you keep thinking equal to
everything you know that's familiar and
the same according to the quantum model
you keep creating more of the same to
change then is to think greater than our
environment to think great in the
conditions in our world the hardest part
about change is not making the same
choice as you did the day before
when you decide to make a different
choice whether it's the change of
something that you eat or to exercise or
to no longer react to certain people or
conditions in your life remember you're
going to feel uncomfortable now that's
not a bad thing that's actually a good
thing that means you're in the unknown
and when you step into the unknown
you're going through dramatic changes in
your own personal biology
when you're in that place of uncertainty
that place of unpredictability that void
that unknown ask yourself what thoughts
do you want to believe in and fire and
wire in your brain what behaviors would
you like to demonstrate that's equal to
a vision of the future close your eyes
and rehearse them review every step
no different than an athlete beginning
to rehearse what they're about to do the
act of rehearsing it begins to prime
your brain to prepare you for that
behavior in your future and then finally
can you teach your body emotionally what
that future is going to feel like before
it happens and when you begin to fall
into the present moment and marry those
intentions with an elevated emotion
your body is believing it's living in
that future reality in the present
moment and you're changing your biology
from living in your past present reality
to living in your future present reality
and your job then is to be able to
maintain that modified state of mind and
body your entire day and if you can
get ready because something unusual is
going to happen in your life it's the
law if you think about gratitude when
when you receive something favorable or
you just receive something favorable if
something's happening to you or
something just happened to you that you
are excited about
you feel grateful so
the emotional signature of gratitude
means that it's already happened or
something wonderful is happening to you
now the body is so objective
that it does not know the difference
between a real life experience that's
creating that emotion
and that emotion that you're fabricating
by thought alone so the body's believing
it's living in an environmental
condition that's favorable to you
and we only accept believe and surrender
to thoughts that are equal to our
emotional state so in the state of
gratitude your body is more prone to be
programmed through its autonomic nervous
system into a different destiny and the
research that we've done
in our in our on our research team shows
that just
four days of feeling gratitude
can strengthen your immune system by 50
percent by releasing a an immunoglobulin
called immunoglobulin a which is their
body's primary defense against bacteria
and viruses is better than any flu shot
and it's the body's natural capacity so
so when we trade
anger and frustration and fear and
anxiety and pain and suffering and guilt
for an elevated emotion the autonomic
nervous system starts to regulate back
into homeostasis and balance and of
course stress is when the autonomic
nervous system is knocked out of
homeostasis and balance it's
dysregulation so we teach people how
to give thanks for the things that they
create in their life actually before it
happens and when we do that properly
we start to see measurable changes in
the person's body and measurable changes
in their energy and ultimately
measurable changes in their life
so the concept of presence is such an
important concept because i think that
paying attention
is being present and it's a skill just
like anything else the more you practice
it the better you get at it and i think
we know when people are present with us
in our lives because they're paying
attention to us and we know when they're
not present with us because they're not
paying attention well where you place
your attention
is where you place your energy bottom
line so if you're thinking about what's
going to happen in the next moment or
what's going to happen in a day or
you're reviewing what's something that
happened three days ago
you're placing your attention in some
future scenario or some past memory and
we siphon energy out of the present
moment and we don't have available
energy then to really begin to create an
outcome in our lives but if we're truly
present
and
we're relaxed and poised in the present
moment
if where you place your attention is
where you place your energy then you
have a lot of energy in the present
moment to execute a lot of energy in the
present moment to make decisions the
more you do this the more you experience
those moments of flow the
synchronicities the serendipity the
opportunities the coincidences because
there's a lot of power in the present
moment so one of the key elements
in the creative process
is teaching people how to relax into the
present moment so if a person is
thinking about their problems and those
problems are memories that are etched in
their brain that are connected to
certain people and objects and things at
certain times and places the moment they
think about their problems say first
thing in the morning when they wake up
if you believe your thoughts have
something to do with your destiny and
your brain is a record of the past the
moment you remember your problems you're
thinking in the past
and because every problem has an emotion
associated because you experience it the
moment you feel unhappy
now your body's in the past so thoughts
of the language of the brain and
feelings of the language of the body and
how we think and how we feel creates our
state of being so most people
unconsciously start their day
with their entire state of being
biologically in the past and again the
body's so objective it doesn't know the
difference between the real life
experience
uh uh and the emotion that you're
creating by thought alone so that past
that familiar past is called the known
and if you wake up in the morning and
you start thinking about
the predictable future and the people
you have to see and the places you have
to go and the things you have to do in
your routine predictable life
the same exact thing happens you're
you're imagining that future scenario
that's already known to you
and you're anticipating the feeling of
that outcome
so that becomes the predictable future
becomes the known as well so if the
familiar past is the known and the
predictable future is the known there's
only one place where the unknown exists
and that's the sweet spot of the
generous present moment in teaching
people how to create from the present
moment
is what begins to produce the magic and
the changes that take place in their
lives
so in order to create a new future
to change something in your life nothing
changes
in your life until you change that's the
that's the story right so
then the question is okay is in order
for me to create something new i'm gonna
have to combine a clear intention that's
a function of the brain and the mind
that's a a process that you can get
better at
and you got to combine that with an
elevated emotion
and that means then you can't wait for
your healing to feel grateful you can't
wait for your relationship to feel love
you can't wait for your uh um
wealth to feel abundance you know that's
that's the old model of reality of cause
and effect and in fact
we're going to teach people actually how
to feel the emotion before it happens
and when you combine that clear
intention with an elevated emotion
that's going to require your heart to
move into balance and move into order it
turns out that's a skill too that you
can practice
so then when you combine those two
elements so that clear intention with
the elevated emotion and you can sustain
that for a period of time
the coherence in the brain the coherence
and the heart actually act like a wi-fi
signal you're starting to put out a
broadband spectrum of frequency and
energy that causes you to feel connected
to something and now you're no longer
trying to get something done or waiting
for something in your outer world to
change to take away the emptiness or
lack you're feeling because you don't
have the experience yet
if people can actually feel the feelings
of the emotions before the experience
happens
they wouldn't be looking for it because
they would feel like it already happened
right so
they teach people how to sustain these
states and if they can
the side effect of that is that you
start seeing synchronicities in your
life those serendipities those
coincidences those opportunities that
you're no longer going anywhere to get
them and you're not trying to control
the outcome or force the outcome or
fight for the outcome or predict the
outcome or compete for it that's that's
when we're matter trying to change
matter when you synchronize your energy
to a possibility in your life and you
start seeing those synchronicities in
your life now when you start seeing
those opportunities occurring you're
going to start paying attention to what
you've been doing and do more of it and
you go then from being the victim of
your life to being the creator of your
life and the cool part about it is you
don't have to go anywhere to get it
somehow out of nowhere it seems to come
to you and
those moments are moments of awakening
so the formula really is about
combining quantum physics with
neuroscience with neuroendocrinology
with psychoneuroimmunology with
electromagnetism epigenetics all of
these different branches of science to
build a model to show people that you
actually can be the creator of your life
i travel around the world and i have the
opportunity to talk to all kinds of
people and one of the things that
independent of people's beliefs
political beliefs religious beliefs
whatever
there seems to be a common thread that
people feel like something's not right
and i think when um you get to a point
where
you realize that no health care plan
no government no religion is going to
take care of you
then who is going to take care of you
and the answer is you right
so my interest is uh to give people the
tools uh and the understanding that
they could heal their body
that they could create a better life for
themselves
that they could overcome past traumas
and scars that were created even as
early as childhood that
tend to be unconscious programs that
keep them repeating the same you know
scenarios in their life uh to teach
people how to induce mystical
experiences so that it changes the frame
of what the way they look at reality
and so
what an amazing time in history to be
alive because consciousness is awareness
and awareness is paying attention and
paying attention is noticing so
so if a person
lives a life as an example
and is diagnosed with a health condition
they're what they're conscious of
is just a certain number of choices that
they could make based on the past
based on tradition based on what's
worked for normal or natural
but what happens when that person has
done the chemotherapy has done the
surgery has done the radiation has done
the vegan diet has done the gluten-free
diet has done the ketogenic diet
has done all the things all the exercise
and they still have the same health
condition
it begs the question
if our personality creates our personal
reality
and our personality is made up of how we
think how we act and how we feel
then the present personality who's
listening to this podcast has created
the present personal reality called
their life not their ex not their
parents not their culture they create
their life so the fundamental question
is if if
if i want to change my life
then that means that i have to change or
nothing changes in my life until i
change right
so the person who's done all these
treatments and still faced with a health
condition this is just an example
all of a sudden says
there's got to be another way
there's got to be something else and so
knowledge
information
when we learn knowledge we learn
information we make new connections in
our brain that's what learning is we're
forging synaptic connections
but that philosophical theoretical
intellectual information is void of
experience
someone who takes that knowledge and
applies it and personalizes
demonstrates it initiates that knowledge
is now interested in
the truth of the experience of that
information
so the person then who becomes conscious
that they could actually heal themselves
by changing the way they think the way
they act the way they feel
if i truly go into the experiment of no
longer thinking the same way no longer
acting the same way no longer feeling
the same way and i start thinking about
what thoughts i do on a fire and wire in
my brain
and if i do it with intention and
attention i'll begin to install
neurological hardware keep doing it and
becomes like a software program it
becomes a new voice in your head it goes
from i can't to i can
no magic there
if you said how would greatness live
today what would love look like today
what would be a greater expression of
myself in the things that i do
turns out if you close your eyes and you
rehearse in your mind
how you're going to be
in any aspect of your day if you're
truly present the brain doesn't know the
difference between
the inward experience of what you're
imagining in the outer real experience
it look the brain looks like you've
already done it your brain looks like
it's already experiencing it now
do that enough times the hardware
becomes a software program and you start
behaving like a different person super
athletes do this this is
musicians athletes dancers everybody
who's good at something is always
rehearsing on their mind that that
rehearsal is just as important as the
physical demonstration it's priming the
brain because the brain is a record of
the past
now you're actually making it a map to
the future you're installing circuits to
use
if you said
god i lived my whole life in guilt i
didn't know it was guilt uh in shame or
unworthiness unself doubt insecurity
fear and all of a sudden you're looking
at that emotion you understand that
emotion is actually down regulating
genes and creating disease you figure
that out you read about it makes sense
then all of the hatred all the anger all
the bitterness you have to someone or
something in your past
is keeping you connected to the past so
you'd say can i teach my body
emotionally
what a new future could feel like
before it happens
not waiting for your wealth to feel
abundance or waiting for your
relationship to feel love or waiting for
your healing to feel gratitude
that's the old model of reality of cause
and effect this is about causing an
effect
turns out if you can elevate your
emotional state
and you can sustain that emotional state
your body's so objective
that it doesn't know the difference
between the real life experience that's
creating that emotion
and that emotion that you're creating by
thought alone your body's actually
believing it's living in a new reality a
new environment now the environment
signals the gene
the end product of an experience and the
environment is an emotion
that person is actually signaling genes
ahead of the environment genes make
proteins and proteins are responsible
for the structure and function of the
body the expression of proteins is the
expression of life okay
every day the person
practices going from the old self to the
new cell this is what's happening in the
world right now
as they start to change and they start
unfiring and unwiring and they stop
conditioning the body emotionally into
the past and practice this
they emerge as a new personality they
become somebody else and like magic
the disease exists in the old person
and there's somebody else now here's
where consciousness comes in
that person comes to a workshop
and they stand on the stage in front of
1500 people and they tell their story
and everybody in that audience is
leaning in
why because they're looking at truth
they're looking at the exam someone who
just got healed from a chronic uh
chronic
i'm talking about stage four cancers i'm
talking about parkinson's disease i'm
talking about rare genetic disorders
and now the person in the audience is
becoming conscious
of a possibility that they were once
unconscious to
and when they see that's possible it's a
four minute mile
i mean four minute mile nobody thought
anybody could break a mile and under
four minutes they said it was biological
yeah physiologically impossible 1400
people have done it already so like this
is the four-minute mile someone's
piercing through a limitation the level
of unconsciousness
and now
that's a footprint in the quantum field
but in three-dimensional reality you're
looking at that person they look no
different than anybody else
and the person says if that person can
do it
i can do it as well i think the ego
is something that is healthy when it's
in balance like if i have a bonfire in
my backyard and those and the flames are
getting a little bit too big and there's
ashes and sparks flying off the bonfire
your ego says david step back you know
it's it's preservational wants to take
care of the body if we're hiking on a
cliff and we come to a very narrow path
and it's a thousand foot drop your ego's
gonna say stay close to the wall don't
go out to the edge you could be injured
and be hurt so the ego has a function to
really in a sense be analytical and and
weigh what we know against what we don't
know and it's healthy the problem is is
when it's
driven by
the hormones of stress and stress is
when your body is knocked out of balance
it's knocked out knocked out of order
that state actually
causes you to be altered and there'll
always be a gap between the way things
appear or the way you appear and the way
things really are you're in an altered
state now for the short term that's
great all organisms can tolerate that
but if you keep doing that for an
extended period of time the arousal
that's created from the stress hormones
actually causes the analytical mind all
of a sudden
to go into overdrive so now the
endorsement of the ego becomes enhanced
and we become selfish that's what it
does it causes it causes us to be
self-indulgent to be self-centered to be
self-important to be self-aggrandizing
to be full of self-pity because in
stress there's only one thing that's
important when you're in survival and
that's you
and so all of our attention goes on our
body all of our attention goes on all
the elements in our environment and we
come become very preoccupied with time
now
when we're in balance
and there's order in the autonomic
nervous system there's health and if
stress is when you move out of balance
autonomic dysregulation
then you are altered from wholeness you
are you are
separate from uh everyone and everything
in your life and you tend to trust less
it's not a time to open your heart in
the jungle the survival gene is switched
on
you don't communicate very well you're
looking at how you can get to where you
need to be or accomplish what you need
to do first and you've got to be there
first and compete because this is all
driven by those stress hormones so the
ego becomes out of balance now here's
the cool part about all of this
when people are driven by those stress
hormones and they don't know how to
change it they don't know how to
self-regulate again it's not that you
react the question is how long are you
going to react if they don't know how to
do that
the problem with most people is they
start analyzing their life
within the emotion that's disturbing
them now emotions are a record of the
past so what we see on brain scans over
and over again when you start over
analyzing and overthinking in a selfish
way
one
hundred percent of the time you'll make
your brain worse and that will have
dramatic effects on your body so when
the heart
is racing because it's pumping blood but
you're sitting in a zoom call and you're
smiling and you're looking at that
person a zoom clone you're thinking
about ways to murder them
you're producing those chemicals but
you're not running and you're not
fighting and you're not hiding so what
happens is the heart is pumping against
a very closed system and it moves out of
order it moves out of balance and now
the autonomic nervous system which
controls and coordinates all other
systems in your body
is out of balance and that dysregulation
causes disease so then the fundamental
question is okay can i trade fear
can i trade anger can i trade
competition can i trade frustration
resentment impatience hostility uh
hopelessness powerlessness whatever
anxiety
for an elevated emotion can i learn how
to
dial down
those stress hormones and practice
feeling elevated emotions turns out
you can do that now the real question is
when you're in your heart you're not so
selfish in fact when there's a change in
blood flow to the heart and oxytocin and
nitric oxide is released you tend to
want to give you you tend to want to
consider the whole and you lead with
your heart
you're not separate from anybody you're
you're functioning as a community
so i think then that um
our future as as human beings is that we
have to be able to
live in an elevated state
in our hearts
and if we fall from grace back into
those survival emotions the key is to be
able to self-regulate and get so good at
it in your meditation with your eyes
closed so good at it that you can do it
with your eyes open now that's when the
game becomes really really important so
when people do the work and they do
their meditations and they come up
against themselves gosh i want them to
i want them to come up against their
fear and in the week-long workshops i
want them to come up against their
impatience i want all those thoughts
that come up to say i can it's too hard
i'll never change it's my ex's fault
it's my boss's fault i want those
thoughts to be right in their face and i
want to give them tools to let them know
that right on the other side of that
that thought right on the other side of
that propensity to want to get up and
quit right on the other side of that
emotion that's keeping them connected to
the past if they're willing to sit in
the fire
to sit with themselves
and instead of getting up and quitting
on themselves learn how
to self-regulate and create brain and
heart coherence i guarantee you every
time they go a little further
and they produce those victories
those victories add up so what's the
side effect of that you return back to
your life you don't need jerk as much
why because you just overcame some part
of your aggression and anger by sitting
with your body and like training an
animal
training a dog i don't know training
the servant
to be present to
to
to
to be greater than the body as the mind
to execute a will that's greater than
those unconscious programs and what we
found out is when people actually apply
some type of formula to be able to do
this
every time they bring the body back into
the present moment it starts liberating
energy
so there it goes the frustration there
goes the impatience and all of a sudden
the unknown which tends to be such a
scary place for most people is the
present moment you see the side effect
of that is the person's more present
they're less preoccupied with all the
things that people spend most of their
attention on now so you overcome the ego
you overcome the personality uh there's
nothing wrong with it it's just you
gotta be able to lay it down
and as you temper your body and your
mind um the ego tends to be less selfish
and more selfless and then the side
effect of that is that then if i say hey
look at david he's actually doing it i'm
going to try it too because he's he's
doing it and research in neuroscience
says you hang out with people that do
things you start your brain synchronizes
and you start doing those same things
it's called an emergence
emergence that's the birds all moving in
the same direction it's a
school of fish moving as one mind and
one heart if you study that you think
there's one leader like that everybody's
following a leader like a top down
phenomenon it's actually wrong it's a
bottom-up phenomenon everybody's leading
so the way we change the world then is
that you work on yourself i'll work on
myself we get to show up and bring our
best and when we're not at our best we
excuse ourselves get back to that state
and we present ourselves back to the
world and i think this is such a great
time in history where people really need
some tools to be able to cope with uh
with all the challenges in the world i
think there's this feeling um that we
all have
that
uh never seems to go away and it's an
intuition it's an instinct that tells us
that there's more to reality than this
dream
uh and and i think that uh people come
to this work for that feeling
and i think that we're greater than we
think more powerful than we know more
unlimited
than we could ever dream and my passion
my interest is to take
science and combine
quantum physics with neuroscience with
neuroendocrinology with
psychoneuroimmunology with
the
epigenetics electromagnetism and i think
science is that language to demystify
the mystical
and to build models of understanding
from a theoretical and intellectual
um
knowledge based
analytical perspective
but that knowledge void of experience is
philosophy but if you can teach people
how
to practically apply it to to
personalize it to demonstrate it to
initiate that knowledge
and do something with it
if they can get their behaviors to match
their intentions or their actions equal
to their thoughts
if they get their mind and body working
together they're going to have an
experience right
and turns out that learning information
makes connections in the brain but
experience enriches those connections
well the moment those neurons string
into place there's a biological change
that takes place in the brain
another part of the brain makes a
chemical and that chemical is called an
emotion and the moment you feel
successful the moment you feel empowered
the moment you feel unlimited
i think now you're teaching your body
chemically
to understand what your mind is
intellectually understood so knowledge
is for the mind
and experiences for the body and so what
we learned in this whole process of
transformation
is that the more people understand what
they're doing
and why they're doing it the how it gets
easier so when the experience then is
causes them to embody the truth
of that philosophy it's no longer
theoretical it's experiential and it's
visceral so the experience then
produces a strong emotion and the
emotion then is what is the information
coming
back to the body
that begins to select and instruct new
genes and we've measured this on people
that they could actually change their
gene expression in in three or four days
by doing this now if you've done it once
it means you got to be able to do it
again right so anybody who's serious
about their own personal growth and
evolution
the replication of any experience will
begin to both neurologically and
chemically condition the mind and body
to work as one so when you've done
something so many times that your body
now knows how to do it better than your
conscious mind now it's innate in you
it's implicit it's automatic it's second
nature it's easy you've become the
knowledge and in a sense you've mastered
that knowledge and you're in a new state
of being so
my interest is demystify that process
so that people have within their reach
all the tools begin to apply it to their
lives we may not be able to control
everything in our outer world
but we certainly can control our inner
world
and so
it's not so important to not react i
mean everybody reacts i react the
question is
how long are you going to react
so if you keep an emotional reaction
going on for an extended period of time
you're memorizing that emotion in your
body as the unconscious mind is
believing it's living in the same past
experience 24 hours a day
seven days a week 365 days a year the
body
doesn't know the difference between the
real experience that produces the
emotion and the emotion that we create
by thought alone so then the emotion
then reaffirms the state and then people
start to use the problems and the
conditions in their life to keep that
emotion going and i would call that an
addiction so we become addicted to the
very life we don't even like
so
it's important then for people to
realize then when you have that moment
where you have crisis or something
breaks down
that you do have control over it and
it's a formula and it's a skill and our
research shows that you can teach people
how to do that and so then when you're
living by some emotion there'll always
be a gap between the way things appear
and the way things really are emotions
alter our perception and if you act
during that time
you'll always say the same thing i
should have never said that i should
have never done that i should never
thought that i should have never sent
that email
so then shortening your emotional
reactions
is a level of intelligence then that
causes you then to recalibrate because
most people don't think they have
control over that they'll say that
person did it to me that circumstance is
the reason i am this way then i would
say
if something in your outer environment
is controlling your thoughts and
feelings then you're a victim to your
environment and yet
how you think and feel creates your
outer world so if you're thinking and
feeling equal to everything that's known
in your present personal reality you
keep creating more of the same so to
change then is to think and feel greater
than the conditions in your environment
and be able to do that to such a degree
then you're no longer reacting to the
same people in the same way
and that takes an effort it's it's not
easy in the beginning but once you start
practicing
uh you get better at it and just like
anything else you start to move through
your life with more coherence and you're
less likely to knee-jerk and if you're
less likely to knee-jerk then you're not
in an unconscious program i think one of
the most important things when we lose
sight of our vision is to make time for
ourselves and i think that when you
invest in yourself
you invest in your future
disconnecting from people in your life
and places that you have to go and
things that you do or things that you
own long enough
to begin to reignite a vision
of how you see yourself or how you see
your future
and begin to emotionally embrace that
future
and change your state of being allows us
to see a whole new landscape if you've
lost sight of your vision
take a moment and remember that vision
and begin to emotionally embrace it and
from that state of being start to think
about the things you want to do the
choices you want to makes write them
down review the behaviors that you have
to demonstrate your goals and
experiences and how it's going to feel
when you do that enough times you're
changing your brain neurologically and
you're changing your body genetically
write down the unconscious thoughts that
you have to stay conscious of become
aware of the choices that you no longer
need to make
review the behaviors and habits you have
to change about yourself and become so
conscious of them that you won't go
unconscious at all during your day
remember the experiences in your
environment that you need to stay away
from whether it's a person or a thing
just for a period of time
so that you can keep that vision alive
and most importantly
review those emotions that keep you
connected to the past and become so
conscious of them and name them when you
feel that feeling that if it's guilt or
sadness or pain the moment you start
feeling it and you become conscious of
it that's when you can begin to change
and if you keep doing this over and over
again the unlearning and the relearning
the breaking the habit of the old self
and reinventing a new self is going to
cause you to arrive at a whole new
future and when you do this could become
your new habit you can't go to the
future
holding on to the biology of your past
decide what thoughts you can bring to
your future write them down thoughts
like i can't it's too hard i'll never
change i'll start tomorrow what's wrong
with me it's someone else's fault
decide on what behaviors or actions or
unconscious habits you have to change
how do you talk do you complain do you
blame do you make excuses do you feel
sorry for yourself just become so
conscious of those behaviors that you'll
never go unconscious again
and lastly you have to decide what
emotions no longer belong in your future
that means if you want to be wealthy you
can take lack if you want to be healthy
you can't take insecurity or fear you
got to begin to condition your body to a
new mind
if you do this
every single day your personality
creates your personal reality and your
personality is made up of how you think
how you act and how you feel change any
one of those things and you change your
life and begin to measure the effects of
you at cause give it a shot your
personality creates your personal
reality and your personality is made up
of how you think
how you act and how you feel
so the present personality who's
listening to this little video has
created the present personal reality
called your life
which means then if you wanted to create
a new personal reality a new life
you would have to change your
personality that means you'd have to
start thinking about what you've been
thinking about and change it it means
you'd have to become aware of your
unconscious habits and behaviors and
modify them
and you'd have to look at certain
emotions that keep you connected to
experiences in the past
and decide do these emotions belong in
your future
the beauty behind this is is that when
you begin to change how you think how
you act and how you feel you should
begin to see changes in your life and i
recommend that you try it out love
inspires us
it inspires us to give
it inspires us to express it inspires us
to serve
to care for one another to be kind to
one another uh to listen with compassion
and understanding
and love actually causes us to
create we become creative in that state
and you've heard me say that when there
is a change in energy there's a change
in your life and an inspiration is a
change in energy
and if you don't change your energy if
you stay in the same energy
then it makes sense that your life stays
the same
so if you can
become inspired
and raise your energy
you become aware of things that you were
once unaware of why because energy
causes us to become conscious of things
we're once unconscious to in other words
you change your frequency
you have more access
to information and that's the name of
the game here so if you stay at the same
level of energy uh every single day then
you will be unaware of possibilities
you'll you'll not be able to create
anything new
so you can't see any possibilities again
from the same energy
in order for you to become inspired by
love inspired by energy
you'll become conscious of possibilities
that you are once unconscious of
now
energy
or energy in motion
uh
they are emotions and so if
we live by the same emotions every
single day
and we haven't changed who we are
and there's a movement happening or
you're in the creative state
and you stay in the same feelings and
the same familiar emotions
then you can't see any possibilities
because you're looking through the lens
of some past experience
and you can only see the same
so then
inspiration then
the word inspiration means
the movement of energy inspiration to
inspire in spirit it is becoming more
energy and less matter the majority of
our thoughts and feelings
are connected to our sexuality
to our victimization or guilt or
suffering or shame or unworthiness or
self-doubt or our importance our control
our fear our anger our frustration our
hatred our judgment those are those are
the first three hormonal centers in the
body and and those first three centers
have everything to do with survival and
those centers are energy consumers
orgasm digestion
stress
is a lot of energy that that we're
drawing from our very vital life force
yes a resource of light and information
and we're turning it into chemistry and
we're literally robbing the body's
energy right so so then living like that
for the short term is okay because the
body can move back to homeostasis it can
restore itself but
when we're over doing that consistently
then there's no energy for growth and
repair there's because you're living
constantly in survival so
again you can eat all the right food you
can do all the right things but if
you're living in anxiety and fear and
you're viewing your world from the worst
case scenario that could possibly happen
because that's what you do in survival
there's no energy for growth and repair
there's no energy for healing so the
majority of our thoughts
are signaling certain circuits in the
brain that signal another part of the
brain limbic brain to make what's called
a neuropeptide neuropeptides are
chemical messengers that signal hormonal
centers so now you're taking thought
and you're storing it as energy in these
energy centers and and if you're living
in survival why would you open your
heart i mean it's just not a time to
open your heart i mean if you're getting
chased by t-rex
it's not a time to meditate it's not a
time to learn it's not a time to connect
it's not a time to communicate it's not
a time to sit down and go within it's
not a time to be vulnerable it's time to
run fight or hide to change is to be
greater than your environment that means
be greater than the conditions in your
life to be greater than the
circumstances in your world and every
great person in history knew this that
means you have to be defined by a vision
of the future instead of the memories of
the past
to change means be greater than your
body those unconscious habits and
behaviors and choices that you've made
over and over again so many times that
the body becomes the mind
emotions that are connected to past
experiences keep you anchored
emotionally to the past and if those
emotions are driving your thoughts and
those thoughts are creating the same
emotions then your body has become the
mind which means that in order for you
to change you're going to have to get
greater than those emotional reactions
habits and hardwired attitudes
that keep you running unconscious
programs and to change then is to be
greater than time if you're waking up
every single day and making the same
choices and demonstrating the same
behaviors and creating the same
experiences and you do that over and
over again it makes sense that your past
is going to look a lot like your future
and your future will be more of your
past finding the sweet spot of the
generous present moment existing in that
place where you're no longer trying to
predict the future
based on the past means you're in the
unknown and when you're in that place
called the eternal present moment that's
where all possibilities exist give it a
try if your personality is made up of
how you think how you act and how you
feel and it is yes or no
and
you stop thinking the same way and nerve
cells that no longer fire together no
longer wire together every place where
one
neuron connects with another neurons
called the memory
so as you begin to unfire and unwire you
prune the very circuits in your brain
that are connected to the old self and
the memory
of the old self begins to mutate begins
to change so then you would say where
is that memory stored and it's stored in
the soul now
as wisdom because you're no longer that
person yes or no
and if you could no longer behave the
same way and nerve cells that no longer
fire together no longer wire together
and pruning is part of biology you don't
use it you lose it
then your memory of the old self would
begin to change and that is a biological
death in the beginning that is
uncomfortable for a lot of people
if you're no longer feeling the same
emotions that keep you connected to the
past and you keep inhibiting that
process
the body will be craving the chemicals
in the beginning because it's been
conditioned that way it's been it's been
addicted it's the mind and it's
anticipating events and the emotions
from those events and you're putting the
brakes on
and that's uncomfortable
and you got to stay conscious and it
takes an enormous amount of energy and
you're no longer signaling the same
genes and producing the same hormones
and your body is no longer being
influenced by your mind in the same way
and sometimes the mind is the biggest
enemy to the body
and you're inhibiting that process
and the body which has become the mind
wants its way
and it's uncomfortable to change and you
got to be able to be greater than that
to truly change and everybody that's
changed has come up against that feeling
and they almost make the same choice and
they don't and they're so glad that they
didn't
and it takes an enormous amount of
energy and awareness to do that
so as the old self deconstructs because
you have the free will to decide who you
want to be on a moment-to-moment basis
and if your life isn't changing and you
want to change your life you got to
change and now you are playing the game
and you are now saying this personality
this person that i've become i'm in the
habit of being it and i want to become
somebody else
and the more you learn about love the
more you learn about life the more you
learn about possibility and potential
the more you become aware of it there
are more possibilities and knowledge is
the thing that gives us that and so the
old self
is a memory like another lifetime like
you can remember it but you're no longer
interested in it any longer because it
no longer defines you
how many people understand what i'm
talking about so then the biological
death of the old self
is crossing a river of change and you
got to stay with it
long enough to become somebody else
and you think it's about wealth it's you
think it's about health it's about who
you become
the people who become somebody else they
they see dramatic changes in their
health and in their lives
and and they can't find the words to be
able to explain it
but it's practical though if you truly
want to change your life you have to
change yourself you would have to be
conscious of your thoughts and aware of
your actions and and familiar with those
emotions and you would never fall from
grace and if you did you would stop and
self-correct
if you truly were interested in
evolution and if you said to me it's i
ca i lost it because of that person
i'd say that you're back to the
unconscious program of allowing your
environment to control how you feel and
think you got two choices stay there
for another six hours or pause and
change your energy
change your energy and get back to the
emotions of your future and the feelings
of your future it's a much better place
to be reason this with me
you could have a great meditation and
condition your body just like you did
into the future
you come back to your senses and you
return back to the same old self romance
in the past again
you're going to weigh that one
50 minute one hour meditation against
the rest of the day back to you
you got to start practicing we have to
start doing it with our eyes open and
the thought
of who we want to become should produce
the feeling of it instantaneously in
other words the thought of your future
should produce the feeling that it
already happened instead of the feeling
of lack because it hasn't happened
how many people understand that the
people who do this well they condition
their body into the future and they say
i don't know how it happened it's like
my body was led right to the event
and your body's going to follow your
mind to an unknown just like it follows
your mind to the toilet every morning
but instead of it being known it's going
to be the unknown
that's where your attention and your
energy has been
i'm telling you it doesn't matter what
you believe in doesn't matter the color
your skin what you eat i don't care it
doesn't matter i've seen it in all ways
so then the thought
of our future
if we're doing this properly should
produce the feeling that it already
happened
if the thought of your future produces
the lack that it hasn't happened you're
still in your past
and nothing is going to change
and it would make sense then that you
would want to get that heart open on a
regular basis
so that you can feel the emotions of
your future before it happens i'm
telling you there's a lot of biology
that changes in you
and you do it enough times you become
that person
a thought of it then produces the
feeling that it's already happened
that's how you know you're getting close
independent of what's going on in your
life
that's when you're mastering yourself
and mastering your life i have sat in
meditations and out of nowhere i had the
most icky
so familiar but so foreign feeling
moved through me that it was i don't
know i never saw it coming i didn't know
what it was
and all i did was
instead of run and turn on my cell phone
or lay down or quit
i was curious if there was something on
the other side of it
so if i stayed present with it
and felt it it was an energy and that
energy is a frequency and that frequency
carries information or the emotion as a
memory however you want to say it
and so you have to pass through the
valley of the shadow of darkness many
times to find the light
and i have sat with my body
curious to wonder if there's anything on
the other side of this emotion
and if i stayed present with it and felt
it it would turn into something else in
time
and so then
think about it you know we have
different sensations that our body
experiences you may feel like a
tightening in your throat and your
respiratory rate going up and kind of
flush
and your heart of
fluttering and you may be feeling
anxious but all of those sensations that
the body is recording your
interpretation of it is anxiety or being
anxious so the sensations then the human
sensations
as information we call it an emotion so
the moment we name it it's anxiety but
those sensations that come up for the
body is information so people then
sitting in the presence of that
information
and allowing you to experience it fully
will cause you to move through it now
for me
i'm all about this
if it's familiar if it's a familiar
feeling
more than likely i'm back in some
unconscious program
because the emotion is driving certain
behaviors certain habits certain
thoughts now that doesn't mean that
people can't go through grieving
processes
but i do believe that that process for
some people becomes a way for them to
get attention
and to get things in their life that
they need
and they use it in a way that becomes
part of their identity and they do that
unconsciously
and so for me i would say then what
greater piece of knowledge
could i learn about grief or about
myself
that i would want to apply to evolve my
experience of it and see if there's
something on the other side of it so
we look for those answers then and we
build a model
and for example people grieve a lot for
for people that die
and i totally get it but if you had a
greater understanding of death
you may not have said grief for that
long because you would say my goodness
if i truly love this person if you pass
this plane and you saw someone you loved
walking around
suffering what would you say to them
after a period of time
hey if you love me live your life
i'm on i'm going on go
enjoy so i always look what is my
limited belief about about something and
could i
learn to to expand my awareness of
what's possible so if you feel the grief
stay present with it
and see by staying present with it if
there's something on the other side sit
with it long enough i i have i've had so
many dark nights i've sat with it until
it turned into something else i just i
just was curious
i didn't want anything out there to do
it
i wanted to do it and when it matters
the most is when it's the hardest that's
what i know what's emerging in the world
now because of information
information is teaching people that
there are other possibilities that they
were unconscious to and you don't need
an authority any longer you don't need a
priest you don't need a governor you
don't need a teacher you don't need a
doctor to gain information any longer
information is available but the
question is
what will you do with it so if you give
people sound scientific information
and science is the language of mysticism
and you combine quantum physics with
neuroscience inner endocrinology and
psychoneuroimmunology and epigenetics
and electromagnetism and make it simple
and don't talk about tradition or
religion or culture that's going to
divide an on the audience but bring the
model of science in
if that person can reason
and understand what they're doing with
that information
and why they're doing it
then the side effect of how they're
doing it is going to get easier
and now the application becomes
essential
so what we're seeing is this emergent
consciousness
where people are taking their power back
and not relying on anyone or anything
for their own personal change or
transformation and i think that when you
get enough people doing it
emergence in biology is a group of birds
all
moving in the same direction of a school
of fish all moving the appearance is a
larger organism they're behaving
in the exact same way there's no leader
when you study that in biology
everybody's leading
so how are we going to change the world
it's not one person not one
consciousness it's a collective
consciousness and the research says
that collective networks of observers
determine reality yet enough people
believing in possibility sooner or later
someone's going to run into that
experience and you need one
once you know it's possible then other
people will start doing it as well just
like the four minute mile so
so in the world right now i think we're
seeing a breaking down
of so many conventions whether it's
religion or medicine or the environment
there's journalism
everything's falling apart right now
because it can't sustain itself because
no organisms
in nature live in this kind of abusive
competition
organisms survive in cooperation and
connection and communion
keep people in fear
keep them angry keep them in pain keep
them all all those survival emotions
you'll never have community
you bring people into an elevated
emotional state something innate
in the human species says we're empathic
to one another we celebrate one another
we want to get along with one another we
want to cooperate we want to resolve
issues together that's
that's who we are
when we're not living in stress and
survival so think about this
if you spend the majority of your day
focusing on matter
focusing on everything in this
three-dimensional world that's made of
material things
it begs the question how much of your
time and your attention do you put on
that unified field
that invisible field of information that
exists beyond space and time
and just like
when you're unaware of your nose it
doesn't exist and the moment you become
aware of it it exists the quantum field
is exactly the same way if you put very
little attention on it in your waking
day
then it doesn't exist for you but the
moment you begin to become aware of it
the moment you begin to pay attention to
it the moment you begin to stay present
with it and to experience it moment
after moment and where you place your
attention as you learned is where you
place your energy
and where you place your attention
causes things to expand
the moment you begin to experience it
not with your senses you experience this
three-dimensional reality with your
senses but you experience it with your
consciousness and with your awareness
the moment you become pure consciousness
is the moment you make contact with that
unified field
and so we now know
the techniques and the tools to get
people beyond themselves
and in fact we know that after thousands
and thousands and thousands of brain
scans that you're at your absolute best
when you get beyond yourself when you
take your attention off your body
when you take your attention off your
identity that's connected to people in
your life the things you own objects you
own places you have to go in time itself
the moment you become nobody no one no
thing nowhere in no time that is the
moment you become pure consciousness
and that's the moment you begin to
connect to that field of possibilities
called the unified field or the quantum
field
and that field is a visible field of
information that exists beyond this
space and time and independent of the
color of your skin
your gender your diet your sexual
preference independent of your
profession your class
independent of all those things that
create separation
that every human being has access to it
i always tell my advancing students you
know when you're changing
is when you stop talking about it
because when you are truly changing
you can't go to church and shake hands
and say peace be with you and then get
in your car and cut everybody off on the
way out of the parking lot you can't say
i don't like the war in iraq and be
arguing with your next door neighbor or
your co-worker
you have to be the living example of
everything you want to see in the world
in terms of change if you don't like
greed start giving
you know you have to demonstrate and
when you do
you give people permission to do the
same
because they're going to observe you
doing exactly what they're afraid to do
but they know it's the right thing to do
so the way
we transform the world is we transform
ourselves
the way you transform a culture is you
transform an individual an individual by
individual when we stop looking outside
of us and you say that world is a
reflection of some aspect of me if
everybody in the world did that
simultaneously imagine how the world
would change and it's not enough to just
focus on peace yeah there's been great
studies that have shown that when a
community of people focus on peace that
the crime rates drop
but when they leave and the research is
over the crime rates return back to the
ceiling value
it's not enough to just think you've got
to demonstrate it you've got to show it
in all areas of your life and when you
demonstrate it now it becomes an example
for people to follow let's say you've
had some pretty rough experiences in
your past
and those experiences caused you to feel
sad and unworthy and guilty
and judgmental
and you've gotten so used to feeling
guilty and unworthy and judgmental
that
that's just
feels normal to you
and then because you feel kind of
victimized
then you blame people and you complain
and you make excuses and you feel sorry
for yourself and that's your personality
and all of a sudden you say
today
i'm not going to do that any longer
because that's the old self
and then you start off your day and it
goes really well for about
two hours
and all of a sudden
the moment you realize that you're no
longer making the same choices
as the day before
you are going to feel uncomfortable
it's going to feel unfamiliar
it's going to be uncertain
there's going to be some
unpredictability
and we now know that people would rather
hold on to their guilt and unworthiness
than to step into the unknown
because at least they can feel something
and so the moment you stop making the
same choices that you always make get
ready because it's going to be
uncomfortable and that's the moment
you're heading towards the new self
and we call it stepping into the river
of change
but now remember
95 percent of who you are
is your body as the mind
you know you've done something enough
times that your body does it better than
your brain
so you may actually
complain unconsciously because your body
does it all the time
and all of a sudden you say no
complaining
no more blaming no more feeling sorry
for myself no more talking about other
people i'm gonna stop
you know what happens don't you
the body starts sending signals to the
brain
the body's been conditioned that way
and all of a sudden you start hearing
the thoughts in your head
that say why don't you start tomorrow
tomorrow's a better day
this is too hard for me i can't change
something's wrong with me it's my
mother's fault it's my ex-husband's
fault it's my ex-wife's fault i'm this
way because of this event or the most
important one
this
doesn't feel right
and the moment you respond to that
thought
as if it's true
that thought
leads to the same choice which leads to
the same behavior that creates the same
experience that produces the same
emotion and the person says this feels
right
that feels
familiar
going from the old self to the new self
stepping into that void stepping into
that uncertainty
is the biological
the neurological the chemical the
hormonal genetic death of the old self
and people will say to us
well in that unknown i can't predict my
life for my future
and we always say the same thing to them
the best way to predict your future is
to create it
not from the known but from the unknown
and when you and i get comfortable in
the place of the unknown that's where
the magic happens
and it never happens in the known if you
have a very brain driven person like
myself
and in some parts i disconnected from my
emotions just to protect me in regular
life
and it's a challenge for me to reconnect
to my old emotions that i already had in
circumstances that would help
do you have any advice
yeah well uh god i have a lot of advice
around that
because um
seventy percent of the time that people
in their waking lives
uh they live in a very protective state
they live in a state of stress or in a
state of survival in fact it's such a
program
that we don't know that we're doing this
we're always
spanning the environment to determine if
it's safe or not and if something
appears out of the predictable or
unknown it alerts us
and we move into a state of arousal and
we begin to turn on the very systems
that begin to say danger threat
possible scenario that's not uh safe
and when that happens
uh we literally begin to anticipate an
outcome
and when we do that we're always
preparing
for what could go wrong
and we begin to create the emotions
ahead of the experience of what happens
if it goes wrong whether it's fear
anxiety
worry
sadness pain we do that unconsciously
that's what a program is
and that becomes the habit
so if you're living in a world where men
have to provide
and show a certain amount of success
and be competitive
then you're not going to open your heart
it's not a time to do that it's a time
to survive and thrive in an environment
and yet
in our work
i see men that if they practice
yeah opening their hearts and it's just
being a child again being a boy again
being curious being wondering
being free being allowing yourself to
let go
we're all faced with
great challenges brilliantly disguised
as impossible situations
and there's always a door there is
always a door
and so
your personality creates your personal
reality it's that simple and your
personality is made up of how you think
how you act and how you feel
so the present personality who's
listening to this show has created the
present personal reality called their
life which means if you're going to
change something in your personal
reality
in your life you got to change your
personality you have to change
nothing
changes
until you change that's the bottom line
you change but you the thought of
changing my personality seems so like
but i like who i am kind of but
i'm also cranky i'm also annoyed
so
like who is that person underneath all
of these ailments i guess all of these
but it's a weird thing to say you change
your personality
well look i mean
there's many things that i love about my
personality just like you do i'm gonna
take that with me but there are things
if i'm going to be defined by a vision
of the future there are things that
can't come because the moment you say i
want to have a mystical experience where
i transcend this three-dimensional world
and and you want to have a really
profound moment a transcendental moment
you start showing up for that and it
doesn't happen right away then what
you're going to start disbelieving you
start to stop believing in yourself
though so the moment we're defined by a
vision of the future that's bigger than
us that vision of the future is not the
vision of the past and when we do that
we take away we take with us
our discipline we take our concentration
we take our
presence we take our passion we take our
strengths with us
all those things you take
but the things that are standing in the
way are those old beliefs and things
that stand in a way that that that that
stop you from connecting to it those are
the things you come up against and and
it's not the it's not the mystical
experience of the transcendental
experience it's who you become it's not
your wealth it's not your health it's
who you become it's not your freedom
it's who you become in the process and
it's the overcoming process that we
overcome that we overcome that we
overcome that we overcome till we
finally become and
so many great people in history you know
even wealthy people people always want
to be wealthy but if you study wealthy
people that really did it they failed
miserably thousands of times until they
figured it out and so you keep showing
up for yourself
enough times
they're going to change you're going to
change you're going to be thinking
differently you're going to be acting
differently you're going to be feeling
differently and that's when the universe
starts to conspire in ways that we just
never even thought about that's that's
that's the beauty behind creation when a
person begins to slow their brain waves
down they have to go when you're in
stress when you're in survival you
narrow your focus on a cause that's
called a what's called a convergent
focus so now you're blessing the energy
centers of the body they're under the
control of the autonomic nervous system
and when the autonomic nervous system
moves out of balance the brain moves out
of balance right we narrow our focus on
the cause and it causes each one of
these different energy centers
to move into incoherence as well and
those little little individual brains
start moving into incoherence and send
an incoherent message to the cells and
tissues and organs hormones then become
down regulated and the body starts
moving out of balance
so when we bless the energy centers or
we reprogram these energy centers two
things has to happen
they have to be able to slow their brain
waves down they have to get out of that
high beta state and the way we do it is
to go from a narrow focus
to a broad focus when you open your
focus when you open your awareness
that's what creates coherence in the
brain because you're going against that
habit
of putting your attention on matter
so there's a convergent focus which is
focusing on matter and then there's a
divergent focus which is focusing on
energy well reality is both particle and
wave matter and energy so if a person
can slow their brain waves down from
beta brain waves to alpha brain waves
now they're starting to fall out of
their thinking brain
right into the home of the autonomic
nervous system okay the person can't
change their brain waves it'll never
work because they're in their neocortex
and their thinking mind right
so that's one thing that has to happen
the second thing that has to happen is
that they have to practice both a
convergent focus and a divergent focus
by the convergent you're focusing on
let's say i'm going to focus on this
energy center right right and then you
move your focus to another energy well
first you first you focus on that energy
center that's particle and then you
focus on the space around it that's a
wave okay and so when you open your
awareness and you're able to do that and
you're in your autonomic nervous system
you can put an intention there which
will create more balance and estrogen
more balance in
your sexual organs you move to your
second center you put your attention
there that's your where you place your
attention is where you place your energy
so now you're beginning to direct energy
yeah into that center but now you become
aware of the space around it why to
create coherence in that little brain
send the coherent message to the cells
and tissues go to your third center
right in the pit of your gut well
there's a huge celiac plexus there solar
plexus a lot of connections in there so
now put your big one that's a big oh
it's getting a lot of signs there yeah
here and here part and solar plexus yeah
that's those are big ones and you tune
in to that energy then you put your
attention in your heart it has its own
individual brain yeah and when you make
energy here when energy finally arrives
here guess where it goes automatically
straight up we've measured it so now
once you start opening your heart you
got more energy in your heart you get
more energy in your brain got it short
on time just go straight to the heart
that's why we do it that's exactly why
we that's why we open the heart so it
creates a field and it begins to drive
energy of the brain so now that energy
is going to cause the person
to have a different consciousness a
different thought pattern right and now
they're going to be thinking possibility
because in survival the first three ones
are all about survival yeah it's really
not a creative process of creating from
mind it's more about a more primitive
you know
humanistic part of us you know animal
part of us so then there's the thyroid
plexus the pineal gland the pituitary
gland so we've seen when people create
coherence in each one of these energy
centers and they do it properly they
know how to change their brain waves
they get into the operating system they
can master convergent and diverge and
focus they're no longer living just this
way they've practiced opening awareness
and focus on energy becoming conscious
of it and as these brains become more
coherent and they start producing
different signals to hormones and
chemicals and into different glands in
the body that's what's being upregulated
to make different different expressions
would you say it's smart to focus on one
goal i mean if you're sick obviously
it's it's smart to focus on getting
healthy but if you have a regular life
and you say you know i would like to
have the classical stuff but more money
uh more wealth more love more joy
would you say in those meditations it's
smart to focus on different goals or
should it rather be the big goal like a
big vision i have for my life that all
the steps on the way are just
marks i will pass at one point well
let's answer that on two levels too
because people come to our workshops for
all different reasons some people come
because they're sick
some people come because they want more
money some people want more a new job a
new opportunity a new career a new
relationship some people want the
mystical
the people come for all kinds of reasons
to me
i don't care
what i care about is that they latch on
to a vision
and they learn
how to create
whatever drives them to that elegant
moment
where they're so present and so
passionate about what they want and they
have a clear intention a clear vision a
coherent brain
and they have an elevated emotion
combined with it that they create hard
coherence and now they're broadcasting a
whole new energy
into the field and whatever we broadcast
into the field
is our experiment with destiny
so i want people
to know the how
because we have plenty of people that
have made millions and millions of
dollars that were living in the backseat
of their car or filed bankruptcy we have
plenty of people that were stage four
cancers serious health conditions that
are healed
but really
people think they come for those reasons
but we come for wholeness
that's why we come that when we feel so
whole
and so happy with ourselves so
connected to something greater
if you feel wholeness
it's impossible for you to want
how can you want when you're whole when
you're whole you feel like you have
everything
so
i want people
to reach that point
where
they feel so whole
that they no longer want and that's when
the magic happens teaching them that
allows them to understand that when they
come back
to their senses they open their eyes
they're not looking
for the experience they feel like it's
already happened and if you feel like
it's already happened why would you be
looking for it
then
if your body is conditioned emotionally
into that future
you're not separate from the energy of
your future you're connected from it to
it but the moment you get in traffic and
you start getting angry
you get on the line at the bank and you
start getting impatient or you're
sitting in a staff meeting you start
judging a co-worker
you just disconnected from the energy of
the future and now you're back to the
energy of your past and you've done
nothing wrong
you just lost your connection to the
future now now the importance of that is
to notice that you're disconnected and
if you say to me well that person
made me feel this way and think this way
i'd say oh my gosh you're back to the
unconscious program of being a victim in
your life the victim is saying that
someone or something is controlling how
i think and feel
but a person who's producing outcomes in
their life all of a sudden they say wow
the way i'm thinking and feeling is
creating outcomes in my life
now i'm a creator of my life and now i
believe less than i'm a victim of my
life what are a few things we can do to
support our inner environment on a daily
basis ah
well listen um the first thing and the
most important thing for me is knowledge
and information
knowledge is really power and and
knowledge and information about yourself
shouldn't it should empower you it
should empower the self right so when we
learn about the immune system and all
that can do and when you say oh my god
you mean not every virus
gets to be in fact no and the more you
the more you understand that and the
more you coax your immune system into
love and into
like we well i just did this little
thing on um
on our social media where i was talking
about the inner army of order what would
be the signal you would want that inner
army to get and so we created this
meditation we said what would
invincibility feel like signal your body
and feel invincible
how would you feel if you had an
uncompromising will
that you had more energy than you could
possibly imagine show your body what it
feels like
because it is that emotion
of invincibility that emotion of an
uncompromising goal to empower your
inner world and you have the intent of
that's what it's for wow get ready
because you're going to start creating a
cadence and a rhythm where your your
body's going whoa what what are the what
is all these new chemicals what are all
these new signals right hey it's time
hey hey uh now all of a sudden receptor
sites on the t cells go wow we got some
new signals coming from the boss here
let's open up all those t-cell receptors
let's go
and in fact we're we're we would love a
little fight right now because we got a
lot of time on our hands and we got all
our receptors turned on
oh i mean that that would be
a signal for your body we also know that
if you could just trade fear
and frustration and
resentment and suffering
uh for an elevated emotion and truly
open your heart again and practice doing
that um
you'll heal you'll heal you'll heal
because i mean all healings happen in
the heart i believe in free will i would
never tell anybody what to believe like
politically or
socially or whatever
i want to provide them the tools and
give them the free will to create life
however they want and believe whatever
they want that's totally cool with me
so those people then
that
want to be healed
and they live in fear
that fear has to be addressed i mean and
it's not easy
because it's re it's hardwired deep in
the limbic brain it's just a safety net
it's a mechanism so then imagine being
in the unknown
that the instinct and the unknown is
it's a scary place
wow imagine not having a body and we
practice lingering without a body in in
in an infinite space and without a name
without a face without a culture without
a job without a social security number
without a disease without a diet just as
an awareness you you practice that
you're going to be comfortable in the
unknown you're going to relax more into
it that's going against
thousands of years
of programming and the people who
actually overcome their
fear and they trade it for gratitude
their immune system gets stronger their
genes up regulated i mean there's just a
host of
everything their brain changes their
heart rate variability
they feel differently and it's it's
being measured and and some of these
people uh we're measuring this now in
our in our events with with reputable
scientists and and universities they're
they're
shocked
at what they're witnessing on a cellular
level on a brain level on a heart level
they cannot believe
the capacity of the body i just
was i just got an email today of assign
one of our scientists said i ran this
three times
the virus
that we expose the cell to in advanced
meditators does not enter the cell it's
outside the cell it won't a virus in
novice meditators some of it's in the
cell some of it's outside controls all
the viruses in the cell there's an
immunity so when the person's less
reactionary to their environment
there's less of response that weakens
them they're less of a victim to their
environment then they're less of a
victim to their environment
large-scale small-scale the body has a
greater immunity to whatever it is i
want to show you what it looks like
when you learn something new you have a
hundred billion neurons in your brain
a hundred billion neurons
the number of connections you have in
one neuron is between ten thousand and
forty thousand connections
if you took
a hundred thousand hundred billion
sheets of paper and you stack them on
top of each other it would be five
thousand miles high
that's the distance from los angeles to
london
if you took a scoop of gray matter the
size of a grain of sand you would have a
hundred thousand neurons in it with over
a billion connections
now
i'll stop right after this slide
learning
is making new synaptic connections
every time you learn something new this
is what's happening in your brain
geniuses
if you learned one bit of information
today
your brain did this
boom
that's learning
physical evidence
as a result of your interaction in the
environment
every time you learn something in your
brain there's a physical change that
takes place and learning is making new
connections
are you with me
this is how fast it happens too
that's learning if you learn anything
this week you've made a footprint
if learning is making new synaptic
connections
then if you keep firing the same
thoughts
over and over again you're going to wire
them in your brain
so then if learning is making new
synaptic connections then remembering is
maintaining them
and all of a sudden they develop a
long-term relationship and just like any
relationship the more you communicate
the more they connect and neurons are
exactly the same way
now as you begin to learn information
neurons tend to assemble themselves
into networks or what's called neural
networks
and neural networks are just gangs of
neurons that have fired and wired
together to form a community of
neurosynaptic connections that's related
to a thought a skill a habit a behavior
a concept
and neural networks are automatic
programs you have a neural network to
brush your teeth to put on makeup to
speak a language to walk
all of a sudden those neurons then form
a hardware circuitry but if you keep
repeating it the hardware becomes a
software program and it becomes
automatic people think that
they want certain things because they're
experiencing lack
and and so
they have to go about
becoming
the very person so then if we reframe it
and you say oh i really want to be
wealthy i want all my needs met and i'll
say really why you want to be wealthy
and they'll say because i want freedom
i'd say okay let's focus on freedom
so now the person understands the
sponsoring thought or the emotion
why would you wait for your wealth to
feel free that's the newtonian model of
reality of cause and effect waiting for
someone or something out there to take
away this emptiness or lack
and what if i'm feeling this emotion
this emotion is influencing certain
thoughts and how i think and feel
creates my life if i'm living in lack
i'm not going to create anything new
but if i say to you hey
when you become that person
once you become it then your your
reality is going to reorganize itself
instead of living by cause and effect
let's teach you how to cause an effect
so then the person then is no longer
interested in getting something in their
environment when they realize it's about
who they become
and all of a sudden now the emphasis or
the
interest is in becoming that person and
we have a week with those people and i
want them to walk as it sit as it stand
as lay down as it i want them to get in
the habit of walking from their room to
the ballroom it's become the new habit
that's why when we do our work you're
we're doing sitting meditations we're
doing standing and walking meditations
we're doing lying down meditations i
want it to become a new habit i want
them to become that person
so then
this happens thousands of times
people come for certain reasons one of
my biggest problems is that i tend to
react quickly to negative situations
how how can i cope with
anger do you have any suggestions or
advice
yeah i'll tell you the first thing
it's not that you react we all react
the question is
how long
are you going to react that's the
question so
we found out that when people react
emotionally with anger
with antagonism
there's an arousal that takes place
because you're turning on the
sympathetic nervous system and the
sympathetic nervous system is a
primitive system saying alex whatever
that whatever that is is a threat to you
and if there's a threat a good way to
deal with a threat is to get aggressive
that's primitive it's animal it's very
animal some people will say oh my god
there's my ex and instead of getting
angry they run
they they they flee they're in fear
they're like the fear is i'm better just
getting away so they they their fear
causes them to run
so
uh when people feel fear when they feel
anger when they feel pain
those are the primary
stimulators that switch on that
sympathetic nervous system and they used
to say
that it's automatic
like it's automatic it happens
automatically that's part of the
autonomic nervous system and you really
don't have any control of it turns out
that's absolutely not the truth so first
thing
is learning how to shorten your response
to the emotional reaction so if you have
an event that happens to your life in in
your life and i say
alex why are you so mad today and you
say oh it's because of this situation
and this person this happened this way
and i would say oh my gosh do you mean
that that person or that circumstance
is controlling
the way you feel
and the way you think
now anything that's controlling the way
we feel in the way we think makes us
victims
whatever that is
now that's okay
but if you keep that emotional reaction
going on
for hours or days and i say to you alex
it's five days what's up and you say to
me i'm i'm upset from something that
happened to me five days ago i'd say you
have a mood
you're in a mood now some people
keep that same emotional reaction going
on
for weeks or months and then i would say
well alex has a
angry
temperament it becomes a temperament
if we keep it going for now this is true
people keep this going for years on end
if it goes on for years now it's a
personality trait
so here's the weird part about it
you ask that person who's been angry for
years why they're angry
and they'll recall an event from 10
years ago or a series of events from 10
years ago and the registered
yeah and the research on the memory says
that 50 percent of that story
isn't even the truth
that they can't even remember the truth
they embellish the story
and make it sound worse than it really
was
to excuse themselves from changing now
what we tell people is
forget
the event
doesn't matter
the details of the event doesn't what
matters
is learning how to overcome the emotion
so when you're sitting in a meditation
and all of a sudden out of nowhere your
body starts getting aroused
and it starts getting frustrated and it
starts getting angry and people say i'm
doing my meditation wrong you know what
i say to them no no no no you're doing
it right
because that has to come up so then
so when they anger and the frustration
comes up and a person's into meditation
they have one of two choices to quit
which is what they've always done
but if you're sitting with 1500 people
and no one else is quitting you're not
going to quit
and if i teach you how to lower the
volume to that emotion and i teach you a
way to change that so the future then is
created by a clear intention and an
elevated emotion now listen closely
that you have to cultivate in your inner
environment of thoughts and feelings
but most people
by the old self are living from past
memories that are created from knowledge
and experience from something that
happened outside of them
some experience or trauma that defined
them
and getting a person beyond the old self
then
is the great work that's what we're here
for
so
we've studied motivation
and i can tell you without a doubt
that the highest form of motivation
in any culture
in any group of people
is what's called purpose motivation
duty motivation or mission motivation
you know what that is
to have a vision to change a culture
that's bigger than you
to instill change in the world
look at elon musk how many people know
who he is
elon musk he created tesla motors
you know him
you know who he is
he created an electric car
that can go from zero to 60
in less than five seconds
and before him electric cars were like
golf carts
that cr you know crawled along the road
and he said
i'm gonna do this i don't know how i'm
going to do it but i have a vision
and i'm going to get the best engineers
in the world
and instead of creating a new product
and selling it to a corporation
i'm going to get a group of people to
share the same vision as me
i'm going to change the world by
changing our reliance on oil
and i'm going to make a difference in
the world and i am going to make a lot
of money
why not
and so people said no that's not
possible and he held on to that vision
and now motor trend magazine
never raided a car
close to a hundred
they rated the tesla car 103.
it's the best car on the road
and it relies on no gas at all that's a
vision of the future and i got run over
by a traffic and
and i broke six vertebrae in my spine
and i had to make a decision at that
time in my life um
because the diagnosis wasn't very good
and neither was the prognosis and
to decide if i was going to spend the
rest of my life on addictive medications
and
with surgical rods in my spine or if i
was going to see if the mind could
actually heal the body and
so that was my wake-up call
in 1986 and so so i just um
i was at the point where i just had to
make a decision to see if it was
actually the truth if if all of this
that i learned was the truth let's let's
apply it and so i was lucky enough to
have a dramatic change in my own
personal health and then i thought god
if it worked on me as it worked on other
people so i started looking into people
that had you know been treating
conventionally or non-conventionally and
and with a certain diagnosis
and their condition was staying the same
getting worse and all of a sudden it got
better and and i just wanted to
uh look at what the cause was that was
producing that effect and so
i interviewed you know hundreds and
hundreds of people that had gone through
the process
and one of the most fundamental elements
that they all had in common with there
were a lot of things that had to do with
their mind and
uh and some people had specific diets
and specific regimes some people use
certain um you know conventional
non-conventional protocols but the
commonality primarily was about how the
mind was really influencing the body and
and
they began to really take a closer look
at how
they were thinking
on a daily basis uh how they were acting
uh on a regular basis and looking at how
they feel uh on a moment-to-moment basis
and
and how you think and how you act and
how you feel is your personality and
your personality has a very direct
relationship with your personal reality
which means if you want to change your
personal reality if you want to change
something about your life you got to
change and so the process of change then
becomes the fundamental process of going
from some person that's familiar and
known to you and stepping out and
beginning to make different choices and
to begin think different thinking
differently and being to behave
differently and speak differently and
feel differently and
and if you start thinking acting and
feeling differently our research shows
without a doubt
you're going to have dramatic changes in
your biology and if you do it enough
times you're going to become someone
else and the disease then all of a
sudden exists in the old personality
and not in the new personality and then
you ask the person where's the cancer
where's the rheumatoid arthritis where's
the immune mediated condition
it's in the old person i'm not that
person anymore that if you have been an
experienced
uh if you had experience of trauma say
for example and it's created the feeling
of fear and your fear is that it could
happen again
and you're you don't know this but every
time you think about that future that
possible worst case scenario scenario
and you feel the emotion you're
conditioning your body to become the
mind subconsciously of anxiety
so now
all you need now is some cue in your
outer environment that says it's unsafe
that if there's damage there that you're
you're a victim something's bigger than
you that could have an effect on you
well now
that feeling of fear
is going to cause you to think thoughts
equal to it
so the person then
no longer needs the environment to feel
that fear they just have to have the
thought about
that condition now and now
they're literally knocking their brain
and body out of balance by thought alone
and the body's constantly living in
emergency mode and it takes a lot of
energy
a lot of resources to live in emergency
mode all the time
guess what system becomes compromised by
the immune system your immune system why
because you have two protection systems
you gotta get a system that protects you
from dangers in your outer world that's
that's the gas pedal that's the
sympathetic nervous system that's a
fight-or-flight nerve system danger
threat out there use all the energy
because you gotta you gotta survive and
when you survive you gotta take care of
your body so right so so now
that system can work really well short
term
it doesn't work really well if you keep
it on all the time because if you're
mobilizing all that energy for some
thread in your outer world there's no
energy in your inner world for growth
and repair there's no energy for
long-term building projects and energy
leaves the brain and it leaves the heart
and it moves into these lower centers
because now you're tapping the body's
resources because there is an emergency
but whether the emergency is real or
imagined
whether your anger is valid or justified
or not
that the you're tapping the body's very
energy to heal by doing this and the
immune system says
well we're part of really the other
nervous system we're the break we're the
clutch we need the we need to get into
relaxation we need to get back into
balance again and when we do then we'll
metabolize then we'll we'll assimilate
we'll reproduce we'll will excrete
properly
so
so now you got this kind of battle
between the gas pedal and the brake and
the immune system says hey listen if
there's foreign agents if there's
viruses bacteria molds funguses listen
we don't have a whole lot of energy here
to deal with them because we're fighting
this war out there there's no homeland
security so they shut down
certain receptors in the immune system
they shut down function
of those lymphocytes those white blood
cells that are your inner army of
protection
and it takes a lot of energy to fight a
virus in a bacteria but if there's no
energy hey listen it takes energy to
raise the body's temperature where do
you think that comes from that's part of
that branch called the autonomic nervous
system and the sympathetic the gas pedal
is part of it and the parasympathetic is
the clutch is part of that autonomic
nervous system and it's a check and
balance let's talk about the
neuroscience of culture
because there is a neuroscience to it
you have a brain that looks just like
the person sitting next to you
and if i was to screw off the top of
your heads
and take out your brain and your
partner's brain someone sitting next to
you and i went like this
and i set them out you probably wouldn't
be able to tell them apart
because you share the same structure in
your brain
and we call that universal traits we
call it gross anatomy
now
because you share the same brain as the
person sitting next to you you smile
when you're happy you frown when you're
sad you sleep at night well this is
mexico you sleep kind of late at night
and get up kind of late in the morning
come on i'm kidding
and you know you grab a stick the same
way we speak a language and because we
share the same gross anatomy of the
brain we have very universal traits that
we have in common how many people are
with me
but now
how your brain is wired
is your individuality
and that's the minute architecture or
the mu minute structure of the brain
so then
your brain is wired different than the
person next to you
because you have different experiences
but if you share the same experiences
because you're in a relationship then
you have similar brains that are kind of
relating
and relationships are built on common
experiences
if we share the same experiences we
share the same emotions and if we share
the same emotions we can relate with
each other
so then think about it like this
you have a hand
and because you have a hand you you have
the same hand as the person next to you
there's only a certain amount of things
you can do with your hand
but now
what makes you unique
is your fingerprint that gives you your
individuality and that is really the
minute anatomy
of something related to a hand are you
with me
so now what is the division that unifies
both the universal traits
and are individual traits
and the answer is culture
culture
and culture is defined by the
environment
in which you live
the environment in which you work
the environment of your family
an environment is made up of just a few
things are you ready
people
objects
things places
time
pets
and that's pretty much your environment
so the culture of mexico city
is defined by the environment
you eat certain foods you like certain
music
you relate with one another because of
the environment in which you live in
and that culture is created from the
environment which is different than the
culture of mongolia
because it's a different environment and
they have different traditions
they have different customs because
they've had to survive in a different
environment and so what unifies
individual individual traits and
universal traits is called culture now
think about this
most cultures
are defined by the customs they have the
traditions the language their survival
skills their habits their attitudes
their beliefs their history their arts
their social structures that have
unified them as an individual culture
are you still with me
so the people you work with the people
you relate with the people you interact
with you share a similar culture that
bonds you both as an individual and as a
species called human beings
and mexicans are different than
australians because they live in a
different environment and they have
different traditions
you still with me
but we could say then that culture
typically is defined by things that have
worked in the past
so then
most cultures then
have a choice
to create a new culture means then you
have to define your culture as a vision
of the future
but most people
their cultures are based on the past
present reality what does that mean we
are in a changing world
and the world is changing faster than
most people can keep up
and if you are going to stay defined by
a memory of the past you will not keep
up with this culture because we are
creating a global culture
so then
what defines
the vision of the future to change a
culture
and the answer is a very clear intention
a clear purpose
combined with an elevated emotion
and when you combine a clear intention
like a vision of the future
along with an elevated emotion of
inspiration and joy you will create an
empowered individual what's something
that you've said in the past that you
were confident about it then but now
upon reflection you're like oh i should
have changed my mind about that oh that
it takes a long time to create reality
i'm going to ask you to expand on that
because i like that answer i want to
know more that's fascinating
well um i think just like anything else
uh you learn how to snowboard you go
through that learning curve you learn
how to ride a bike you go through that
learning curve
uh that that i used to think that
creation was hard
i just thought it took a lot of energy
and it took a lot of sacrifice and had
to work for it and great onsen and uh
god i mean even my definition of
surrender
today is very different than it was just
three months ago because i'm always
doing it
and so
i think that
it doesn't have to be that way i just
think that it could be any way you want
and that and then working on that
changing that belief we call these
people self-starters this is
entrepreneurial motivation
this is when you say
i'm gonna do this because i said i was
gonna do it
still a high form of motivation but not
the highest form
but what we know
that people who have purpose motivation
naturally are personally convicted
their their personal conviction is in
alignment with their purpose
because they have a reason to get up
every day if someone is so
disconnected to their future their
greater future self if they're so
negative thoughts suicidal thoughts
often
hurting themselves potentially often
what can they start to do to just give
some a little bit of relief and peace in
their heart yeah it's simple knowledge
experience wisdom
philosophy initiate that philosophy
master it yeah
mind body soul
thinking
doing being learning with your head
applying it with your hands knowing it
by heart
and this is the journey of knowledge
because when you learn that information
and you really study it you are going to
begin to see the world differently
because your brain is changing then when
you start saying how can i use this how
can i apply it how can i personalize it
how can i do something initiate this
information what am i going to do how do
i get my behaviors to match my
intentions now this is the act of trial
and error it's so important you don't
make it the first time you don't give up
you get up and you try to walk again
and you start learning how to do this
and so as you begin to do it over and
over again you start having new
experiences yes well new experiences
enrich the circuits in your brain
philosophically and now the brain makes
a chemical and now you're feeling more
unlimited you're feeling more whole
you're teaching your body chemically to
understand what your mind intellectually
understood stood and now you are
literally literally starting to embody
that knowledge yes it's becoming
signaling new jesus new information but
but you can't do it one day and expect
your wealth to come you got to do it
over and over again yeah so the
repetition of re practicing over and
over again neurochemically conditions
the mind and body begin to work as one
you've done it so many times the body
now knows how to do it subconsciously
just like it just like i knew how to
subconsciously lean into trauma and
victim mode right decades now the body's
getting new information it's going to
adapt and and now
you're going to literally become
that knowledge you're going to be coming
that's what you're going to become and
so now that's when you no longer have to
try it's who you are it's yes yeah
you've memorized an internal order
that's greater than anything in your
outer world that's going to tell you
something else and i was looking uh
closely and there are people
that do
this work do do this transformation work
in the meditations that we teach and
they're so impatient and they're so
entitled
uh and they want an instantaneous change
from the lack and pain they're feeling
right that they never overcome
themselves in their meditation they
never overcome themselves in the
meditation and when they finish their
meditation they believe in this work
less
then there are people who say
i can tell you the moment i made up my
mind to change
because i had reached the end and i made
a decision
and that decision to change carried an
amplitude of energy that was greater
than the hardwired programs in my brain
and the emotional conditioning in my
body and my body literally responded to
my mind in that moment that the choice
that i made became a moment in time
i would never forget and they'll tell
you and that's the moment i remembered
when i was gonna change now
those people then when they sit down to
do the work there
the chemotherapy hasn't worked
uh the injections didn't work uh the
radiation didn't work
uh the surgery didn't work the diet
didn't work the yoga didn't work this is
this is now their end they have nothing
else to believe in but themselves
and they go all in not 50 not 60
they're going all in they have nothing
else to believe in
now listen
when they go a little bit outside the
gnome they got they went a little
further than where they normally would
stop they pushed themselves to that next
limit
they started believing in themselves
that they could do it a little bit more
they
they finish the meditation and they get
up and believing it's it's it's working
more than working less they're the
person that's believing in themselves
that's why because it's not the work
it's your belief in yourself right it's
and then when you believe in yourself
you believe in possibilities when you
believe in possibilities you got to
believe in yourself who was he going to
believe in we had bond university
a university in australia on the gold
coast
senior researcher took the large
majority of my brain scans
and they hadn't she had them analyzed by
her graduate students and they
statistically looked at everything
one of the most startling things for the
research team
was our community's ability
to go to
to get to that point where they're
nobody no one no thing nowhere in no
time i'm talking four seconds i'm
talking five seconds i'm talking nine
seconds just like just give me a second
i know how to do this they they've
practiced it enough times that the
creative moment is when you get beyond
yourself when you dissociate from
everything known in your material world
turns out when you do that and you start
changing your brain waves
your brain waves slow down into alpha
and theta
you're suppressing the memory bank of
the known self that keeps you plugged
into three-dimensional reality when you
quiet down this mechanism
now
all of a sudden you start connecting to
that field and when you can stay
conscious in those subconscious realms
when you can literally regulate and
change brain waves now you're in the
operating system where you can make
those significant changes well here's
the deal with trauma and it's kind of an
interesting thing because when you're
traumatized
some threat or some danger or some
condition in your outer world
through your senses is changing how you
feel in your inner world
and the quotient of change between the
way you normally feel
in some alarm state when you change your
internal state and move into that
emergency mode you narrow your focus
on the cause and the brain
freezes an image and takes a snapshot
and that's called the long-term memory
and now that image is branded
holographically into the brain
so then
they remember experience experience is
better because we can remember how they
feel and and that memory then changes
the person's biology
so they think neurologically within the
circuits of that experience and they
feel chemically within the boundaries of
those emotions and how we think and feel
becomes our state of being
so now the person
biologically has changed and many times
it's the strong emotion that begins to
select and instruct the gene that
creates disease why
because
if the environment signals the gene and
that's the truth that's epigenetics and
the end product of an experience in the
environment is an emotion
the emotion that you feel from that
event is literally selecting the gene
for you to begin to change and genes
make proteins and so the the person if
it's if it's strong enough begins to
wear their trauma not just in their
brain
now it's in their body because every
time they think about that trauma every
time they review it every time
they keep creating the imagery they keep
firing and wiring the circuits in their
brain
and they keep feeling the feeling
emotionally in their body and their body
is so objective
that it's believing it's living in the
same past experience 50 to 100 times a
day and all you need is a stimulus and
response an image and an emotion a
thought and a feeling and you're
conditioning the body into the past well
you're conditioning the brain body into
the past why is our memory
for
pain stronger than our memory of a
success or a joy i really think that
when the survival gene is activated
preservation is the key so we can have
10 things
that happen really great in our lives
you have a family member or somebody you
know that does this they have 10 really
great things happen in their one thing
bad and they focus on that bad thing why
because the survival gene is activated
they want to make sure it doesn't happen
again so so you put your attention on it
because
you don't want it to happen again so
what people do when they're aroused is
there to start thinking it's going to
happen so they actually select the worst
case scenario in their mind
and then emotionally embrace that future
before it happens
and they're conditioning their body to
become the mind of anxiety and fear so
in preservation and in survival if you
prepare for the worst
anything less that happens you have a
better chance of surviving so that's the
mechanism that takes place so
survival means you better take care of
your body yeah you better be aware of
your environment and make sure there's
no threats and so you got to keep your
eye out there
and you better be thinking about the
future based on what you learned in the
past now there's nothing wrong with that
when the analytical facilities are in
balance but when there's an arousal
arousal there's three things that create
arousal fear
hostility and anger or aggression and
pain
and that arousal drives the brain
into these high states of what we call
high beta
and most people need something or
someone or some circumstance or some
drug or some pill or some computer game
to change that internal state and the
moment they notice a change in their
internal state then they pay attention
to what's causing it they start
developing a dependency on it right
so
it turns out that when we teach people
how to self-regulate and change their
brain waves
we could actually see then that the
incoherence the disorderliness that's
taking place in the brain you know when
you're over aroused you're overly
analytical and you're shifting your
attention from one problem to one person
to one thing to one place to another
problem to another circumstance to your
phone to your car and each one of those
elements has a neurological network in
the brain so the arousal causes these
different circuits to fire out of order
and the brain is incoherent so take two
waves that are out of phase and mix them
when they interfere they flatten out
there's no energy so energy leaves the
brain right
so then
when you're in arousal you narrow your
focus on the cause if there's something
rattling in the bushes and it's dark you
freeze and you narrow your focus on it
and there's a rush of adrenaline your
pupils dilate and your heart starts to
race and you're ready to run fight or
hide i mean that's a survival moment but
what if it's your co-worker
sitting right next to you or six feet
away and and you're judging them you're
the same arousal's taking place and
what's once very adaptive becomes very
maladaptive now this is where it gets
challenging so when we teach people how
to open their focus we've done
thousands and thousands of brain scans
and they get beyond their analytical
processes and they open their awareness
and go from a convergent focus to a
divergent focus and they learn how to
relax and regulate their brain waves
start to slow down into alpha and then
if they do it properly and they're
connecting
those different compartments of the
brain that were once firing out of order
start to unify different communities
form bigger communities the brain starts
to synchronize and then all of a sudden
you start seeing different compartments
of the brain all in resonance so now
when they're all in resonance and they
start interfering when those waves come
together there's more energy in the
brain
so when a person dials down the
mechanism this neocortex that plugs us
into three-dimensional reality that
keeps us aware of our body that's the
autobiographical self where everything's
stitched in memory in there when we
start deactivating the mechanism here
and we get beyond the memory bank of the
known self and brainwaves move into
theta we
we've studied this so much
when a person can let their body
be in a light state of sleep and feel so
safe
that you can finally let go and
surrender the body is
sleeping but the mind is awake and now
the door between the conscious mind and
the subconscious mind is wide open and
if they can regulate and stay there
something amazing happens
there's a release of energy
from the body and their brain goes into
a very very super coherent state of
gamma
gamma is super consciousness now i'm not
talking about
a little gamma i'm not talking about a
lot of gamma i'm not talking about a
really loud gamma i'm talking about a
supernatural amount of gamma
there's so much order
and so much energy in the brain like if
we were in an audience and we were all
clapping like this
that could be alpha right theta would be
and if everybody could do this the
slower we could do it the more we can
get our timing down the more we can get
coherent but if we were doing
this it would be really hard for all of
us to do that at the same time it takes
a lot of order a lot of awareness a lot
of energy to be able to
create that kind of
order so
that's how fast the brain is and that
arousal
that's taking place is ecstasy
that arousal is bliss it is the most
familiar
unfamiliar feeling that people ever have
in
that memory then
that the person has that is so
profoundly different
than the feeling of success
the feeling of wealth the feeling of
orgasm or love or whatever this is a new
one and it's a thrill
and the person notices a dramatic change
in their inner state
and with that experience comes a very
lucid picture a very profound insight a
download of information
that's the moment then
the body many times rewrites the
biological program energy
is in forming matter and the autonomic
nervous system is regulating it's in
high order and remember disease is
autonomic dysregulation
now it's getting into a very very high
frequency of order and it's sending very
coherent information to the cells and
tissues sending energy to the cells and
tissues and cells begin to emit more
coherent light and information and then
there's the disease
and there it's not the recognition that
when you're assimilating a negative
thought or a negative judgment
or a negative emotion envy
greed whatever it may be
that's actually lowering your energy
yeah and when you get to that place
where you're experiencing that
incredible bliss right here you can't
you can't yeah and even if you have the
thought and the thought will still come
because we still have those stories but
the thought
will be an understanding correct of
human nature because you're no longer at
that vibrational level anymore you're
rising above it you know and and i think
more and more people are starting to
figure that out and and and the people
in their lives are like no my husband
my husband is a changed person no he's
not the same guy i know him i know he's
completely different and the guy is just
like yeah i feel amazing i feel great
and all it was was sitting in the fire
yes for a little bit of time until the
body finally moved out of the past into
the present moment and so
the causes of this like i always say you
never know
what you're doing today and how you're
doing it who you're going to affect
tomorrow when you do this work and
that's what we're seeing and people are
they're they're they're getting
promotions
uh they're getting all these wonderful
things not because
of anything that they're doing
they're just different yeah and people
notice that and they want those people
in the position to make better decisions
for the whole and i think that's that's
how we change the world can you believe
in a future
that you can't see or experience with
your senses yet
but you've thought about enough times in
your mind that your brain is literally
changed to look like the event has
already occurred
latest research in neuroscience
says you can change your brain from
living in the past to living in the
future
and can you fall in love with that
vision
to such a degree
that you come out of your resting state
and change guilt or suffering into
inspiration and joy and gratitude
to such a degree that your body as the
unconscious mind
does not know the difference between
that external event and what you're
creating internally
so that your body believes it's living
in that future in the present moment and
you begin to signal new genes
in new ways
to change your body
to look like the event has already
occurred
the latest research in epigenetics says
you can change your body by thought
alone
now reason this with me
if there's physical evidence
in your brain and body
to look like the event has already
occurred
your brain and body are no longer living
in the past they're living in the future
and you will walk right into your vision
most people in this audience
all of you
have done something great in your life
you all have
no reason this
you woke up one day or you had a wild
thought out of nowhere
and that thought
was a possibility in the future
something new you wanted to experience
and the moment you started thinking
about this experience
the moment you started contemplating
this potential reality
you turned on a part of your brain
called the frontal lobe
the crowning achievement of the human
being
it's forty percent of your entire brain
it is the creative center
and it has connections to all other
parts of the brain
and the moment you said
what would it be like to be a leader
what would be like to be successful what
would it be like to have this vision
come true
the moment you asked that open-ended
question
you turned on this part of the brain
because the rest of the brain is just a
bunch of automatic programs
and now the frontal lobe the creative
center wakes up
and it has connections to the entire
brain it's the ceo it's the boss it's
the symphony leader of the brain
and the moment you get creative the
frontal lobe begins to select different
networks of neurons that are stored in
your brain from things you've learned or
experienced
and as you begin to think a what-if
question
it begins to select these different
networks and begins to seamlessly piece
them together
and making your brain fire in new
sequences and in new patterns and new
combinations
and whenever you make your brain work
differently you're changing your mind
because mind is the brain in action
mind is the brain at work
and the moment those neurons fire in
tandem
you get a picture in your mind
a hologram
a vision
an abstraction
and for those people who are passionate
that thought that their thinking
begins to create an elevated emotion
they become inspired
they feel enthusiastic in theos filled
with god
they become passionate
they started to open their hearts
and all of a sudden they're combining a
clear intention with an elevated emotion
and it's the combination of a clear
intention and an elevated emotion in our
research over and over again that proves
then the person now is changing
fundamentally
changing biologically
changing internally
and their brain and body are moving from
living in the past into living in the
future we have such compelling evidence
in science with brain scans you make
your brain work better you can make your
heart work better you make your immune
system work better you can make your
cells go from really sick to really
healthy we've got great evidence you
could become immune to serious viruses
you can be immune to the bacteria we've
got the measurements you can blame in
your life
we have great evidence and the people
aren't monks they're not they're not
nuns they're not religious scholars are
just common people
and then we have testimony
of people who are the example of truth
they are they are the example of truth i
would rather have dinner with those
people than anybody anybody out there
they know something right
so evidence then becomes the loudest
voice right and and that's what i think
what people are looking for right now
the truth is so lost in sensationalism
and the truth is so lost
in emotional agreement
and so people who want to feel fear
they program themselves and accept
believe and surrender that people who
want to be hate be hateful
it's all there it's all there and it's a
it's a matrix to find the way out right
and
and i think i think there's a door i
just i just think that we have to
trust the innate information that that
comes from within us
really incredible moments uh in the last
year were people that were traumatized
from childhood that were abused sexually
physically emotionally that were
suicidal that all kinds of health
conditions they came to the edge
of that emotion that kept them connected
to the past and they were ready to give
up in one meditation because
they they never had felt an emotion like
this that they could remember that it
was so intense
and they thought about all the times for
the last year that they never missed a
day of doing a meditation even when they
didn't feel like it or whether they
wanted to quit halfway through and they
didn't they went all the way they
thought about all those times
that they went to that point and they
went one more time really and their
words are always the same
and my heart blew wide open
and i look back at my entire past and i
don't want to change one thing in my
past because it brought me to this
present moment and i can see my
betrayers
i could
see the people in my life
that had a hand in this and i have
nothing but compassion for them
because now the person is no longer
viewing that path from the same level of
consciousness they're viewing it from a
place of love of wholeness and they see
the greater good of all of it and now
their their
their their conditions their health
conditions their endometriosis their
uterine tumors i mean whatever it is
literally
goes disappears and they have an
incredible incredible change in their
brain chemistry they're in love with
life they're off their meds they're not
suicidal they're why would they be
they're free
so it can happen in an instant when the
heart is healed and everybody gets the
new signal the body's out of the past
the body's no longer feeling the
emotions of the past and sometimes
we got to come right up against that
edge that's yeah that's the great moment
our immune system is kind of like our
rudimentary nervous system it has cells
that are mobile and they're called
plasma cells or white blood cells
and their job is an internal defense in
many of our bodies plasma cells
line the mucous membranes gut
the digestive tract
all the orifices of the body the nose
the mouth ears
and it's a line of defense against
foreign invaders and toxins and when the
immune system is facing
some foreign invader whether it be a
virus
a bacteria a mold a fungus
some foreign agent
it is the army of plasma cells that move
towards the danger
and begin to
attack these foreign agents
and
there are cells in your immune system
called t cells
and t cells are like the ninjas of the
immune system
they release uh very powerful chemicals
that can
denature and break down any foreign
invader
and t cells have these little trumpets
that stick out on the receptor site so
picture this big circular spherical glob
and you have all these different
receptors and these t cell receptors are
these long trumpet
appendages
and when they come up to a virus or they
come up to a bacteria when they come up
to even a cancer cell
they notice that it's a foreign agent
and immediately this t cell receptor
attaches to that foreign agent and
begins to release a lot of unhealthy
chemicals that begin to cause that
foreign agent to to die and then
memorizes
that foreign agent and passes the
information onto the army of the rest of
the white blood cells in the body and
this is a strong immune system and when
plasma cells and white blood cells
begin to function well they release
chemicals called immunoglobulins
and immunoglobulins are proteins that
are in the shape of a y and those y
shaped proteins are antibodies and what
they do is when the the white blood cell
releases an antibody
it begins to block the receptors
of the foreign agent that's trying to
attack
uh the white blood cells so when a
healthy immunoglobulin is uh released
it suppresses
the
the warfare uh the the cell receptors
that are trying to attack the white
blood cell and now you have a strong
defense you have a strong immune system
and yeah your body right now is doing
that in fact your body is always
evaluating all those foreign agents
whether it's a virus a bacteria or even
a cancer cell
and it's working to keep the body in
balance and the immune system a strong
healthy immune system does that
constantly always behind the scenes of
your awareness if you give people sound
information
and then they can repeat that
information
they're wiring it in their brain
they're creating a new model of
understanding
if you show them how to apply that
information
if they do it properly they will have
some type of transformation
that transformation
isn't something that causes people to
feel bad or unworthy it causes them to
open their hearts
it causes them to feel joy
to feel gratitude they feel differently
and if you're able to then
create that elevated emotion
and you teach people more information
they will continue to transform
themselves and that's called evolution
if you think the same thoughts the same
thoughts always lead to the same choices
the same choices lead to the same
behaviors the same behaviors create the
same experiences and the same
experiences produce the same feelings
and you're now caught in your old self
but
new thoughts
should lead to new choices
and new choices should lead to new
behaviors new behaviors should create
new experiences and new experiences
should create new emotions and that
should inspire evolution
we say that your personality
creates your personal reality
and your personality is made up of how
you think
how you act and how you feel we could
say that your personality is your state
of being
so now geniuses
if you keep thinking the same thoughts
keep demonstrating the same behaviors
keep living by the same feelings and
emotions your personal reality is going
to stay exactly the same
but
if you have new thoughts
that lead to new choices that
demonstrate new actions that create new
experiences that cause you to feel
differently you will begin to walk into
a new future how many people understand
this
so most people try to create a new
personal reality as the same personality
and it doesn't work
you literally have to become someone
else
so
crossing the river of change going from
the old self to the new self requires
you stepping into the unknown
and if you are now in the unknown and
you feel uncomfortable because you're
leaving guilt behind
you leave unworthiness behind you see
the biggest problem with most people
is they want to create wealth but they
feel lack
they want a new life but they feel
unworthy
that's mind and body in opposition
and our research shows that you can
teach people how to recondition their
body to a new mind
and when that occurs
they begin to create very powerful
things in their life what do you believe
is the purpose of life overall
to figure out the purpose of life
okay i know i mean i mean i i really
think it's i think the mathematics
that i've looked at says
there's infinite experiences to have you
will never know the end
so then
if you study any religion i i mean i've
looked at a lot of them
this concept of eternity that the soul
is going to be around for eternity
that's a long time
and that means you got to be okay with
you
for a very long time yeah so
i think it's i think it's the creation
of more experiences and i think
to to
i think we came from source from
singularity from oneness
and we have descended down into density
a fooled by our senses into separation
and every
single being has a spark of oneness of
the divine within them and we got so
separate
that we now have our own free will to
answer the question is there more
because if your oneness it gets kind of
boring after a while like is there
anything else well the moment you ask if
there's anything else you're no longer
oneness you're something other than
oneness right and you're a a different
consciousness separate from oneness
so i think then we live life and then
when we can predict the feeling of
everything that can happen in our life
and gets boring and
we're not impressed by anyone or
anything we ask the same question
is there more and that's when the soul
goes
all right well it's been how many
lifetimes you've been doing this okay
there's an awakening and the and we ask
that question and then all of a sudden
we start getting information and books
and stuff and meet people and it gets
exciting and and it's the it's it's how
the universe works and so we climb out
of this and i just think there's so many
incredible experiences that are left in
the unknown
that we get to have and and then of
course when
the journey is over and you evolve to
that point
then you take that wisdom and you went
you say here's what i learned and it was
scary down there and i was like boy i
tell a great story and then you hang out
there and you go
is there anything else besides and here
we go again it just never
inside or that's my theory so how do we
brainwash ourselves
in times of stress and anxiety
in order to become more peaceful loving
and successful
in the future how do we brainwash
ourselves in a different way
sure
well um
that's what uh i have spent just about
my whole life
and and um
wow i mean
the first and most important thing is
that you have to understand
that if 95 of who you are is a set of
unconscious programs
then the first step is lighting a match
in a dark place if you want to become
someone else you got to become aware of
who you are
yes that means you got to start thinking
about what you've been thinking about
you got to start paying attention to how
you speak got to be conscious you
demystify the word meditation and the
word meditation literally means become
familiar with yeah when you become so
familiar with your thoughts so aware of
your emotions so conscious of your
habits that you wouldn't go unconscious
to them again now you're no longer the
program right so so getting people
disentangled from that program we found
out as a formula and when we teach
people how to do certain things with
their focus
and opening their awareness when we
teach them how to create a very
disorderly brain that has been driven by
the hormones of stress into a more
orderly coherent brain and teach them
how to open their focus and practice
that they'll come up against those
thoughts and they'll become so familiar
with them listen to this they won't
believe him anymore when they come up
any longer wow and so when they hear him
in their day they'll be like that's not
going to stop me from my future
so if they're sitting there and they
want to quit
just because they're sitting still
and they're not quitting
then they're developing a will that's
greater than those programs and you're
breaking out of the shell and you keep
doing that you're going to get up and do
the work every day because you did it
yesterday and you're going to want to do
more of that because you're getting out
of your past and it feels better and if
you keep doing that and you keep feeling
better every day the question is why
wouldn't you do it every day because you
would ultimately just feel better and
then the more whole you feel means the
more you are connected to your future
imagine if you felt every single day
and this is what i do work on
if i could stay connected to the
emotions of my future all day long
there's no way i would be looking for
when it would be happening how could i
look for when it would be happening if i
feel like it's happening i wouldn't look
anymore which means i wouldn't be
separate from it and that's when you
start creating the magic right that's
when you're in that zone and that's when
that reaffirms that personality that
you're becoming and now you don't you
know wake up in the morning oh god i
gotta create my future now you're you're
you're gonna jump out of bed be excited
you're not gonna want that magic to end
if you're alive in this world and you
haven't been experiencing the quickening
i mean i mean
you know i said to uh
someone the other day
the day where you end your day and feel
complete because you finished all your
work you'll never have that you know
there's always more emails and more
things to check right so the demand has
has has pressed us into this crazy realm
of
of
of of um multitasking
and i think that
you start shifting where you place your
attention is where you place your energy
so if you're shifting your attention all
over the board your energy is scattered
yeah so then when you start
disconnecting from everybody your boss
your co-worker you know the news uh your
cell phone your computer and you start
going this way
i think it's uh into the present moment
then of where you place your attention
is where you place your energy and
you're truly in the present moment
you've got a lot of energy to execute
you've got to let that energy to use and
you want to be able to do that eyes open
the more scattered your energy the less
you have to focus on pushing one thing
forward that's why people's dreams don't
happen because too scattered
there's no look look if you keep putting
your attention on some future experience
that you are imagining with your mind
your body is going to follow your mind
right there because that's where your
energy is but if you're putting your
attention on everything known in your
life the shower the coffee maker you
know
the toilet and your body's following
your mind every day to the known but we
want your body to follow your mind to
the unknown right enough people get to
doing that
and you could do better in creating
things in your life that we see this
wealthy people in our work that have
focused on wealth some of them living in
the back seat of their car some of them
bankrupt that now have multi-million
dollar companies what do you think they
want to do with that money
they want to give it away
let me tell you why not because of any
other reason is that they now know that
they create more right well why why if
you're abundant why abundance to me has
changed abundance means i have more than
i need like way more than i need so if i
have way more than i need and i know how
to create it then take it i'll create
more of it so now you're no longer
holding on and scarcity
you're making a difference so wealthy
people that have created a lot of wealth
in this work they want to give back they
want to make a difference and i think
that that's how we're innately wired i
think we're all innately wired to care
for one another to make a difference in
the living organism our living organism
our community we heal one another that's
what we do right we inform one another
we encourage one another we support one
another
we shine for one another not to outshine
another person to shine to show them if
they can shine and that's that to me is
super healthy so then i'm i'm applauding
your success because i want you to
succeed because you're telling me that
if you can do it i can do it so so
there's no longer any separation i think
that's hopeful for the world then you
start celebrating diversity then you're
like wow you're way different than me i
wanna i wanna study you because i wanna
bring that into who i'm becoming yeah
you create a strong community that way
what are the things that
disturb or
disconnect our awakening and connection
to the divine a lot of times when people
they hit that point they try to
reproduce it the same way as we talked
about and you can't yeah you can't do it
the same way because that's redundancy
but also many times uh we have the
experience and we start to try
and because trying is matter trying to
change matter and and so we're forcing
we're controlling we're predicting and
and then the uh and when we do that then
of course we're in separation and we're
waiting for the event to happen to feel
the emotion right and
i've done that
long enough and it's actually have to
lay down
the very thing we used our whole life to
get what we want for something greater
to occur and it takes practice of
surrender right
so
that's one element i also think that our
response is emotionally like
let's just say that a person gets
connected to the future they get
connected to the energy of their future
they feel it it's really great and then
they start their day and then two hours
later they're feeling something else
because some person or some circumstance
altered their state well
they just disconnected from the energy
of the future and now they're back to
the energy of the past don't expect
anything to change in your life because
then work that way so then
then when they get back to that old self
again then they say what's wrong with me
i failed they didn't do it right no
that's all the program you show up again
and you go after it again
so familiar feelings
cause us to no longer see through the
lens of the future we're seeing through
the lens of the past
and and we color reality that way so
um
i think i think familiar emotions uh get
in the way as well and then of course
there's always belief
and a belief is just a thought you keep
thinking over and over again until you
hardwired in your brain and all beliefs
are based on past experience so a person
has an experience the stronger the
emotion they have from that circumstance
the more they pay attention to the cause
and the brain freezes a frame takes a
snapshot and that's called the memory
the moment they draw a conclusion about
that experience they'll think
neurologically within those circuits and
they'll feel chemically within the
boundaries of the motion thinking and
feeling thinking and feeling
belief becomes an unconscious or
subconscious state of being they don't
most people don't even know they have
beliefs about things about god about
relationships about money because it's
it's not a conscious thing it's a
subconscious thing yeah so in order to
change a belief or a perception
about yourself and your life
you got to go all in
it's not like you go 50 and you got to
go all in you got to make a decision
with such firm intention
that the amplitude of that decision
carries a level of energy
that causes the body to respond to the
mind that the choice that you make
becomes a moment in time you'll never
forget and you would say i remember the
moment
i made up my mind to change and the
stronger the emotion you feel the more
you'll pay attention to the decision and
that's a huge stone you drop in the
quantum field big splash big waves so
your brain is organized to reflect
everything you know in your life
your brain
is a record of the past
it's an artifact
of all the things you've learned and
experienced to this moment
so if you wake up every morning
and get out of bed on the same side
shut the alarm clock off with the same
finger
shuffle into the bathroom and use the
toilet like you always do
go and get a cup of coffee and drink
coffee out of your favorite mug
then get in the shower and wash yourself
off in the same routine way
drive to work
get to work see the same people
that push the same emotional buttons
do the same things that you've memorized
and do so well
then hurry up and go home and hurry up
and check your emails
and hurry up and check your facebook and
then watch your favorite television show
then hurry up and go to bed
here's my question
did your brain change at all that day
we could say that you were thinking the
same thoughts
performing the same unconscious actions
living by the same emotions but secretly
expecting your life to change
so there's a principle in neuroscience
and the principle says
nerve cells that fire together
wire
together so if you're thinking the same
thoughts
making the same choices
demonstrating the same behaviors
reproducing the same experiences that
stamp the same networks of neurons into
the same patterns
and then produce the same emotions
you're going to hardwire your brain
into a very finite signature
because as you fire and wire the same
circuits in the same way
those circuits begin to become more
connected
and by the time you're 35 years old this
is science now
we become a set of memorized behaviors
unconscious habits
automatic emotional reactions beliefs
and perceptions and even attitudes that
function just like a computer program
and if you do something over and over
and over again
the repetition of those actions
over time conditions your body to know
how to do it well better than your mind
and a habit is when your body knows
better than your mind
where you've done something so many
times that the body now knows how to do
it better than the brain
and so 95 percent of most people's
behaviors
attitudes thoughts beliefs
emotional reactions are subconscious
programs
so why is that important
because you're here this week
to learn new information
and every time you learn something new
you make new connections in your brain
that's what learning is
learning is forging new synaptic
connections
physical evidence
as a result of your interaction in the
environment
and the footprints of consciousness is
called learning making new connections
and the nobel prize laureate kandel in
the year 2000
found that when people learned one bit
of information
they doubled the number of connections
in their brain
from thirteen hundred connections to
twenty six hundred connections
but if they didn't review that
information
if they couldn't repeat it
if they couldn't remember it those
circuits pruned apart in hours or days
so if learning is making new synaptic
connections
then remembering is maintaining and
sustaining those connections your body
rejects viruses all the time of course
it has memorized certain viruses that
you've been exposed to
it's memorized certain bacteria that
you've been exposed to and it's beaten
those viruses not every virus wins in
the body the body has an intelligence
and it's and it has
quite a library of memories in the in
the white blood cells so your body is
fighting viruses and bacteria all the
time there's a constant competition
going on really so our research shows
that four days
of opening your heart
releases immunoglobulin a your body's
primary defense against bacteria and
viruses it's better than the flu shot
it's the body's natural flu shot and
that's the innate intelligence of the
body saying i got this i got a lot of
energy in fact i got a surplus of energy
in fact i'm radiating energy and now too
much around the world my outer world is
not controlling my inner world my inner
world now is functioning independent of
what's going on in my outer world and
now
you're manifesting your manifesto ah now
you got it now you're in a creative
state because people are coming to you
yes right exactly now you're a magnet
now you have a field right and you have
energy
to heal and our research shows that that
field around your body will actually
expand you you radiate more light and
information cells
are getting new information that that
are causing
light to be exchanged between cells and
information now the body's getting an
upgrade so
so that immunoglobulin a in four days
went up 50
so now we now know that if it's going up
50 that then the immune system was
getting a new signal and nitric oxide
then
causes another chemical to activate the
arteries in your heart to swell and now
just like when energy moves into your
sexual organs and swells of blood and
you have energy there the same intensity
it moves into your heart
and now
now the heart is activated and what do
you feel
you feel an incredible amount of love
yeah and love you you feel you feel
whole and now the more whole you feel
our research shows
then the less separate you feel from the
things you want in your life because you
feel like you already have them you only
want things when you're in lack but when
you feel whole then it feels like it's
already happened and that tends to be
the exact emotion
that causes those synchronicities and
serendipities and coincidences to happen
in our life and you say to a person what
are you doing and they're saying i'm not
doing anything
i'm just loving life i'm being myself
i'm yeah right i'm free i'm free from
the past i'm free from my story of the
past in fact i'm more connected to the
energy of my future than i am to the
energy of my past i think that if we
share the same experiences because we
like the same things
we share the same emotions
and if we share the same experiences we
share the same emotions i can relate to
you so we can exchange ideas and
information yeah and if we share the
same energy energy is information so
many people as an example
they use each other to reaffirm their
their dependency on suffering so i
suffer more than you than you say i you
i suffer you suffer more than me we have
this thing we just complain with each
other well that's the same resonance the
same frequency and there's a match right
uh but goes to the same means if you if
you're if you're
someone who's has a uh accountability
partner that that you exchange ideas
like this with and it's a different
frequency and different energy so when
energy comes together and it's
constructive something comes out of it
yeah you feel it right it's and you feel
an elevation if there's dissonance then
your your sensing meter is how you feel
about that person many times in your gut
or in your heart or wherever and there's
decon there's a
destructive interference and there's no
energy involved so
i think that's just a practice but
really
the ultimate mastery
is to be able to be in such residence
such coherence
that when you walk in the room that you
raise
everybody's energy and you don't let
your energy drop because of any
circumstance or any condition and that
would be greater than your environment
right and that's that's the model
that we use so imagine 1 500 people
in an event
where everybody's getting super coherent
and the interference that's going on in
the room is creating these high
amplitudes now we've measured that in
the room and the energy in the room is
off the chart many times there's i mean
there's energy for healing in there
there's energy for all kinds of things
that can happen so we brought it to life
with our awareness and so
the more elevated the emotion love
gratitude freedom bliss ecstasy the
higher the frequency
so but it turns out you can have a
collective group of people with a lot of
energy and be incoherent and it creates
entropy yeah you could have a smaller
group of people that are highly coherent
and put out a very big signal
so when we see a collective really get
coherent
wow the energy in the room opens up
doors
of possibilities that i would i would
never expect i mean i i don't i don't
know how to explain some of the
phenomenological things that happen
but that's that's everybody's divine
like everybody's everybody's in that
state they're they're in that elevated
state so
i think our i think our truth meter
is really whether we feel it lifted
uh or we feel like we've been robbed
because if you are not
defined by some vision
that is bigger than you
and you are not passionate about that
vision then you're left with the old
hardware of the past in your brain and
you will be predictable in your life
so would you agree then
new thoughts
new information should lead to new
choices
new choices should lead to new behaviors
and new behaviors should create new
experiences
and new experiences should produce new
emotions
and those new emotions should drive new
thoughts and that's called evolution
so if your brain is a record of the past
and you don't have a vision of the
future
then you are living in the past
and you will never arrive at that new
future that if you have been an
experienced
uh if you had experience of trauma say
for example and it's created the feeling
of fear and your fear is that it could
happen again
and you're you don't know this but every
time you think about that future that
possible worst case scenario scenario
and you feel the emotion you're
conditioning your body to become the
mind subconsciously of anxiety
so now
all you need now is some cue in your
outer environment that says it's unsafe
that if there's damage there that you're
you're a victim something's bigger than
you that could have an effect on you
well now
that feeling of fear
is going to cause you to think thoughts
equal to it
so the person then
no longer needs the environment
to feel that fear they just have to have
the thought about
that condition now and now
they're literally knocking their brain
and body out of balance by thought alone
and the body's constantly living in
emergency mode and it takes a lot of
energy
a lot of resources to live in emergency
mode all the time
guess what system becomes compromised by
the immune system your immune system why
because you have two protection systems
you gotta get a system that protects you
from dangers in your outer world that's
that's the gas pedal that's the
sympathetic nervous system that's a
fight-or-flight nervous system danger
threat out there use all the energy
because you gotta you gotta survive and
when you survive you gotta take care of
your body so right so so now
that system can work really well short
term
it doesn't work really well if you keep
it on all the time because if you're
mobilizing all that energy for some
threat in your outer world there's no
energy in your inner world for growth
and repair there's no energy for
long-term building projects and energy
leaves the brain and it leaves the heart
and it moves into these lower centers
because now you're tapping the body's
resources because there is an emergency
but whether the emergency is real or
imagined
whether your anger is valid or justified
or not
that the you're tapping the body's very
energy to heal by doing this and the
immune system says
well we're part of really the other
nervous system we're the break we're the
clutch we need the we need to get into
relaxation we need to get back into
balance again and and when we do then
we'll metabolize then we'll we'll
assimilate we'll reproduce we'll
excrete properly
so
so now you got this kind of battle
between the gas pedal and the brake and
the immune system says hey listen if
there's foreign agents if there's
viruses bacteria molds funguses listen
we don't have a whole lot of energy here
to deal with them because we're fighting
this war out there there's no homeland
security so they shut down
certain receptors in the immune system
they shut down function
of those lymphocytes those white blood
cells that are your inner army of
protection and it takes a lot of energy
to fight a virus in a bacteria but if
there's no energy hey listen it takes
energy to raise the body's temperature
where do you think that comes from
that's part of that branch called the
autonomic nervous system and the
sympathetic the gas pedal is part of it
and the parasympathetic is the clutch is
part of that autonomic nervous system
and it's a check and balance but so you
stay in emergency for an extended period
of time
and now you're exposed to some
antigen or some
external substance some foreign agent
when we become the living example of
truth when we actually embody this
that
there are no limits to what we can do
and i'm hopeful with human beings that
um that we have this capacity
and
and of course when we believe in
ourselves uh we believe in possibility
and when we believe in possibilities we
believe in ourselves and i think that is
the ultimate belief
memory is creative that in fact fifty
percent of that story you embellish
people make up that story let me tell
you why they make up that story
because they excuse themselves for the
fact that they haven't been able to
change
since that event they'll have to make it
sound worse than it really was to make
it harder to grow and change
so that they can reaffirm their limited
sense of their inability to change so
then that story becomes more and more of
a story it's less of the truth because
you got to work yourself up into a state
there were lions and tigers and there
was right you know there were
helicopters snowstorms and yeah
everybody was firing bullets
worse than you could possibly imagine
and then you've got to feel that emotion
right and then you're looking oh yeah it
must have been really bad now that's
that's your identity now that's your
identity you think
60 to 70 000 thoughts
in one day
out of those sixty to seventy thousand
thoughts that you think in one day
ninety percent of those thoughts
are the same thoughts
as the day before
so if you believe that your thoughts
somehow are connected to your life
then the same thoughts always lead to
the same choices
the same choices always lead to the same
behaviors
the same behaviors create the same
experiences
and the same experiences produce the
same emotions
and those very same emotions drive the
very same thoughts
and your biology
your neural circuitry
your neurochemistry your neural hormones
and even your genetic expression
is equal to how you think how you act
and how you feel
and how you think how you act and how
you feel is called your personality
and your personality creates your
personal reality
that's it
so then if you wanted to create a new
personal reality
a new life
then you would have to start thinking
about what you've been thinking about
and change it
you would have to become aware of your
unconscious thoughts
and observe them
you would have to pay attention to your
automatic habits and behaviors and
modify them
and you would have to look at the
emotions you live by every single day
that are connected to your past
and decide if those emotions belong in
your future
you see most people try to create a new
personal reality
as the same personality and it doesn't
work
you literally have to become someone
else
in our community at least people who
have relationships that are built uh
from our community uh tend to be more
long-lasting because they're more
self-aware and so there's no blame
there's no excuses there's no make wrong
there's no competition there's none of
that there's just this is who i am you
know and i think that the ultimate goal
is
when you reach the point in your life
when how you appear to the world
is who you really are that level of
transparency is it takes no effort right
you can be yourself and and and you know
people say to me wow you're you're
pretty approachable and i say
well god i work so hard every day on
overcoming myself in the morning
overcoming my ego why would i want to
build it up the next day because i got
to face that guy again tomorrow morning
so why not just keep you know you know
taking those edges and smoothing them
down so that so that
you're you're less
unconscious to all of those programs
that are built in relationships you
asked if is it possible then can that
people can heal that quickly in one week
yeah because what if they create an
inner event
that carries an amplitude of gratitude
or joy or freedom breakthrough from the
chains of the past and when the body is
liberated and you feel that elevated
emotion
the stronger the emotion you feel from
that breakthrough the more you're going
to pay attention to the image in your
mind and now you're now beginning to
brand new circuitry in the brain and
your body's being conditioned into a new
future and the stronger the emotion you
feel and the more you pay attention to
the picture the more you're conditioning
the body over time to the future instead
of the past so now
you keep knocking on that genetic door
emotionally
then that emotion ultimately signals a
new gene
that
up regulates that gene to produce better
proteins and the person then all of a
sudden starts healing and we have
research to show
that people can do that in four days
signal genes to reduce cancer cells and
wow
just to signal stem cells to to suppress
um
uh to go to active tissues and repair
them and regenerate them and suppress
inflammation well you know you come with
a lot of genes and they're just a
library of potentials they're just a
storehouse of information of
possibilities so then you've got to get
the right signal the right lock into the
key that begins to select and instruct
genes that cause genes to make different
proteins and you can regulate so many
different genes the same genes you can
regulate them differently so when they
up regulate they start producing really
healthy and robust proteins and that's
that's enzymes that's tissue that
structure that's function that's
hormones
it's immune immunoglobulins when they
down regulate because of some alarm when
there's not a lot of energy
for long-term building projects well
then you keep doing that then the body
starts producing cheaper proteins it's a
different signal it's not a time for
growth when you hit pay dirt like that
when you connect when you connect to the
field when you connect the divine
whatever you want to call it when your
consciousness merges with a greater
consciousness and that arousal creates
ecstasy bliss oneness whatever you want
to call that
you realize that it never came from
anything out there it didn't come from
the wardrobe or the facelift the sports
car whatever
it came from within you and so you stop
looking out there for it and now the
love affair begins and you never want to
miss a date because it's just too good
so that memory then
that is what i'm after because when you
have those transcendental moments and
you understand this yeah
the experience of that transcendental
moment
lays down new circuitry in the brain
that's what experience does
and the experience produces a feeling
but it's not chemical it's electric and
it's orderly and every cell of your body
is
jiggling in an order and there and
you're aroused and you're awakened right
you have to admit when that occurs
your spectrum of reality is going to
broaden some conditioning
some illusion
something is removed and you start
seeing reality as it is and all of a
sudden you start seeing the part that we
edit out for survival
now you start seeing patterns and lights
and information
that are transcendent of
three-dimensional reality and your
spectrum why because your brain had the
experience and the circuitry is there
and now your your experience of the
world changes you get an upgrade to the
to the vr set the virtual reality said
oh you got the upgrade you got 2.0 and
now it looks different everything looks
different everybody looks different the
world look you're seeing beauty more
well and there's more holism and more
connection and sounds and words and
music and sense and sight and light is
all working together
i mean that's the blessing of an
awakening right that's where that's
where we're going what do you think the
world humanities challenge will be over
the next decade as we enter 2020.
um back to the principle lewis of just
different paradigms beginning
to collapse
you know economically politically
socially environmentally
religiously education journalism the uh
you know medicine
um
they they have to
uh move into chaos
and chaos is just unpredictable
yeah exactly but now here's the
challenge for humanity
you have one of two ways to embrace the
breakdown of those those those paradigms
you can face them with anger and
hostility and fear and you are only
contributing to more of it
we have to see that those breakdowns are
essential for something greater to
happen
now
we can't wait
for governments to take care of us
that's we can't wait for
uh medicine to to give us a drug that's
going to heal us from a condition
the truth is with a greater level of
consciousness
the change in awareness because of
information
the greatest challenge we have as those
as those paradigms break down is to no
longer emotionally react in the same way
and be victims you can't say this
president this person this this whatever
is actually making me feel this way and
think this way basically you're in the
program that you're something outside of
you is controlling you
how you feel and how you think
so then to self-regulate then is to say
how i think and feel was going to change
my outer environment so then
we're all faced with great opportunities
brilliantly disguised as impossible
situations and we are at that point at
that nexus point in our evolution as a
species so then you don't try to fix
that that's never going to work what you
do is you create something better
and then everybody just naturally just
leaves that
and goes here now it used to be some
people would just come here and the
majority would stay here because they're
clinging to
what they've been programmed or
believing but now
because of information everybody's like
that's not going to work i already know
it's not going to work and i don't care
what anybody says this is working for me
so
people are moving to new to new um
to new applications to new paradigms
because it's working for them so as long
as we don't emotionally react to the
breakdown that's happening
currently in the world and chaos is just
unpredictable order you know as as as
things move towards disorder the novelty
that's being created is literally chaos
because
the known
and everything staying the same is order
but as you step out into that unknown
it's then you're having the chaos is
unpredictable order being expressed
through novelty and we have to be able
to learn how to take that
disorder and with the application of
brain and heart coherence create more
order so you can't just say hey i'm
standing up for peace and you know and
being being
miserable with your co-worker you you
don't get to talk about peace
until there's you you're the you're the
living prayer of peace not just we know
we know crime rates go down and
violence goes down when there's peace
projects in communities where there's
meditation on peace but when
those peace gathering projects end you
know you see that crime and violence and
everything returns back to the same
level so it's not enough to just think
it
we got to demonstrate it so if i'm
demonstrating peace and you're
demonstrating peace somebody else
because of mere neurons is going to go
wow that person's unpredictable wow
they're different it's given me
permission to do the same
so i think that
ultimately moving into that state of
being you know as human beings and and
and creating unity
that you know you keep watching so many
programs on television that talk you
into prejudice that talk you into
separation that talk you into fear that
talk you into violence to talk you into
war deceit negativity
um you're you're not going to trust
anybody in fact you're going to see
difference between you and me or anybody
because that's what separation does but
when you're heart centered and you feel
connected you don't see the person any
longer right you see something
transcendent you see in essence right
and i think if you do that really well
that kind of emergence of a of a new
consciousness
that's less dependent
on on all of those outer things it's
really difficult to control and you want
to control a community control their
emotions
and control them in survival when you
overcome your emotions
you can see the hidden meaning behind
all things and when everybody's looking
this way you may be looking that way
because you understand look you've just
overcome your fear you've just overcome
your hostility and anger you've overcome
the program of whatever it is
i swear to you you are going to be able
to connect people and that that then
is the hope of the future
feelings and emotions are the end
product of past experiences
and you can remember experiences better
because you can remember how they feel
and when you're in the midst of an
experience
all of your senses plug you into the
environment
and as you're gathering all this vital
data from your external world
all that information rushes back to your
brain
and it causes jungles of neurons to
organize themselves into networks
the moment those neurons string into
place the brain makes a chemical and
that chemical is called a feeling or an
emotion
and once you feel that emotion you
create a long-term memory
now reason this with me
if feelings and emotions are the end
product of past experiences
and you are feeling the same way
every single day
doesn't that mean nothing new is
happening in your life
and if those feelings and emotions drive
certain thoughts
and you can't think greater than how you
feel
because you had events in your life that
have branded you emotionally
and you feel sadness or guilt or shame
or unworthiness or insecurity
all of those emotions are created from
past experiences
and when you feel those emotions
and those emotions drive certain
thoughts
and then those thoughts make certain
chemicals for you to feel the same
emotion
and then those emotions drive certain
thoughts
the repetition of that cycle then
conditions the body
to memorize that emotional state better
than the mind
and now your body
literally is in the past
because if you can't think greater than
how you feel then you are thinking in
the past
and so most people then
spend the majority of their life
talking about
why they never arrive at their vision of
the future
because of some past experience
and so if feelings and emotions are the
end product of past experiences you
remember your first kiss
you remember your wedding you remember
the birth of your children you remember
catching a fish off the coast of
manzanillo with your three best friends
because you caught the fish and it was a
new experience and you felt great
and then you went
to the casita and you cooked the
mahi-mahi and you drank sauvignon blanc
and the wind was blowing off the sea and
the sun was setting
and you made a long-term memory
but you also have memories that are
connected to trauma and crisis
to disappointments
and those are the memories that people
remember more than anything else
and so if you haven't overcome some
emotion
that keeps you anchored to the past
then you tell a story about the past
and people say
i am this way because of this experience
that happened to me
15 years ago
i am this way because of some event that
happened 30 years ago
and from a biological perspective
it means i haven't been able to change
in the last 15 or 30 years
and scientific american
a prestigious magazine
says that 50 percent
of what you talk about in your past
isn't even the truth
you make it up
because you don't have the same brain
that you did 15 years ago or 30 years
ago
so then your brain and body are
typically in the past
because thoughts are the language of the
brain
and feelings are the language of the
body
and how you think and how you feel
creates your state of being
so if you think insecure thoughts in a
matter of seconds you are going to feel
insecure
the moment you feel insecure
your brain is monitoring how you're
feeling and you think more insecure
thoughts
which then makes you feel more insecure
and the repetition of that cycle
conditions the body to become the mind
of insecurity
and then the person says
i
am
insecure whenever you say i am anything
you are commanding your mind and body
into a destiny
so then how do people change
they wait for crisis
trauma
disease
diagnosis loss
something has to go wrong in their life
where they feel so uncomfortable that
they finally make up their mind to
change
and why is that
because after the trauma or the crisis
they don't feel like of themselves
and the moment they don't feel like
themselves they could actually observe
themselves
because they are looking at themselves
through the eyes of someone else
but my message is why wait
you can learn and change in a state of
pain and suffering
or you can learn and change in a state
of joy and inspiration
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome to get
some incredible bruce lipton motivation
check the video right there next to me i
think you'll love it continue to believe
and i'll see you there and i say fine
did it change your life and the answer
is no
you have to take the knowledge that you
are walking within your conscious mind
and put that knowledge into your
subconscious programming